STATE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER.
FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE
JUDICIARY BUT WE ARE STARTING AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE RATHER NEW
COMMITTEE THE WHOLE BECAUSE WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET.
BUT I'M WE HAVE.
MEMBERS PRESENTING AT OTHER
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SO SORE
GONNA HAVE A LOT OF IN AND OUT
TODAY.
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS ASSEMBLED
AND WE DON'T WANT TO DELAY WE
WILL START OUR HEARING.
SO WE ARE BEGINNING.
ON PART A WHICH IS -- THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WE HAVE A
VOTE ONLY ITEM.
WHICH WE WILL -- WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF VOTE ONLY ITEMS WHICH
I'M GONNA HOLD AND NOT DO YET
OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THE OTHER
MEMBERS ARE NOT HERE.
AND SO I WILL START WITH A
DISCUSSION ITEM WHICH IS ISSUE
FOR AND THAT IS THE BROADBAND
COMMUNICATION.
A NINE ELEVEN IN NINE ONE ONE
IMMIGRATION AND SUCH SO IF -- WE
COULD HAVE MR MID.
BIGGER **** AND MR CAREER
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT TOO WILL
BE PRESENTING [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SHOT MY AS YOU AGE
SAID NINE MY NAME'S MITCH MEDI
GIVE IT SHOULD GET THE DIRECTOR
CALLOW YES CELL AND I OVERSEE
OUR LOGISTICS.
ORGANIZATION WITH ME TODAY IS MY
COLLEAGUE A BUNCH CAREER.
WAS A BRANCH MANAGER FOR A NINE
ONE ONE OFFICE -- IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY AND TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT -- THREE
CRITICAL ISSUES FACING US WITHIN.
AND I WON AREA. FOR IT -- THOSE
THREE COMPONENTS INCLUDE
BROADBAND.
AND THEN SOME BRIDGE FUNDING
THAT WERE LOOK FOR TO MAKE US A
HOLE FOR THE UPCOMING US SESSION
AND THEN -- OUR TRAILER BILL --
SOLAR EACH OF THOSE -- THREE
INTER TWINED TOGETHER BECAUSE
ARE ALL SET IN A FUNDED.
FROM THIS OF THE BROADBAND.
INITIATIVE FOR US IS SUCH.
A REQUEST FOR A LITTLE OVER
MILLION DOLLARS AND AUTHORITY
FOR SIX POSITIONS.
THAT WE CAN HIRE THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO INTERFACE.
WITH -- OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS --
SPECIFICALLY FOR INTER
OPERABILITY AND HOW WE'RE GOING --
TO OVERSEE AND CONTINUE TO
ADMINISTER -- OUR INTEGRATION
WITH FIRST AT AND HOW ORGAN
TÁI FIRST IT TOGETHER WITHIN
THE NINE ONE COMMUNITY SO.
THAT INNER OPERABILITY ISSUE FOR
US AND IT'S AN OVERSIGHT ISSUE
FORCE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS KIND
ENOUGH -- TO FUND US FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS THROUGH A GRANT.
THAT GRANT HAS EXPIRED AND
THERE'S NO FURTHER FUNDING --
FOR THEM TO SUPPORT US WITH ANY
PERSONNEL THAT WERE.
I'M USING TO ADMINISTER AND
SUPPORT THAT FOR US.
THE BRIDGE FUNDING.
AS A AS A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
BRIDGE -- INFUSION TO ENSURE.
THAT WE CAN NOW CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT NINE ONE ACTIVITIES.
THROUGH THIS -- COMING FISCAL
YEAR.
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH OF FUNDING TO SUPPORT US.
AND IN THE TRAILER BILL OF
COURSE IS THE COMPLETE
RESTRUCTURING THE TRAILER BILL.
AND HAS -- WILL ACTUALLY BRING
US INTO.
FULL -- MODERNIZATION EFFORTS
FOR THE TAX REVENUE CODE I'M SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
ISSUE OF DECLINING REVENUE. FOR
OUR NINE ONE ONE PROGRAM IN
ACTION BEFORE WITH THE
INITIATIVES.
THAT IN PLACE FOR FOR US.
THE TRAILER RULES CRITICAL TO US
BECAUSE OUR REVENUE CONTINUES
DECLINE IT'S A MATTER OF FACT.
AND IT'S OUR CONDITION FUND
STATEMENTS ARE VERY CLEAR ON
THIS LAST YEAR WE TOOK IN A BOB
ACTUALLY SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN TEXAS.
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ANNUALLY
TO RUN THE LEGACY HARKEN TO
EXISTING NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM --
SO.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW AT LEAST
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THAT TO ENDEAVOR.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATIVE BRANCHES HAS ASKED
US TO MODERNIZE AND DIRECTED US
TO MODERNIZE.
OUR NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM.
WE'RE PREPARED TO DO SO BUT WE
NEED A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
SOURCE TO DO THAT SO -- THE THAT
EFFORT ALL HINGES ON THE TRAILER
BILL PASSED ALLOWING US TO
RESTRUCTURE -- THAT PROCESS.
FROM OUR STANDPOINT THE TRIGGER
BILLS -- FAIR IT'S EQUITABLE --
THE RATES WILL BE AMONG THE
LOWEST IN THE NATION -- WHEN WE
SET THEM?
AND THE BENEFITS ARE EXCEPTIONAL
FORCE FOR NEXT GENERATION.
NINE ONE ONE DOMINIC TO TURN
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE A BUNCH
CAREER AND YOU CAN GO IN TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE FEWER EXAMPLES ON
SOME OF THE BENEFITS FROM THE X.
GENERATION I'M ON ONE
MODERNIZATION.
I'M GOING TO INTERRUPT AND
ESTABLISH REFORM WE HAVE ROLL
CALL.
I UNDERSTAND.
NEVER MORE LONG [inaudible]
SENATE ABOUT.
RIGHT WERE NO.
A REAL COMMITTEE SO.
YOU MAY CONTINUE WE'RE ON THE
ITEM ON THE NINE ONE ONE
INTEGRATION IN THE EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BUDGETARY ON THE NINE
ONE BRENT BRANCH MANAGER AND
OVERSEE THE NINE ONE PROGRAM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AS AS MITCH SAID -- OURS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS -- IS
BEFORE YOU IT'S PART OF THIS
BUDGET PROCESS.
WANTED TO GIVE YOU JUST A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE DIFFERENCES AND
AND THIS TRAILER BILL VERSES THE
THE BILL THAT.
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
SO ONE OF THE CHANGES IN THAT
TRAILER BILL IS -- LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A RANGE FROM TWENTY TO
EIGHTY CENTS THIS YEAR WE'VE
REMOVE THAT BOTTOM END SO
ESSENTIALLY IT'S ZERO TO EIGHTY
SENSES THE RANGE -- THAT THAT
BILL CAN BE SET.
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF DISCUSSION
IN THE FLOOR DEBATE LAST YEAR
AND AS WITH THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THE TRAILER BILL AND HOW
EXACTLY THAT RATE WOULD BE SAT.
SO WE WANTED TO KIND OF BRING
THAT BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- YOU KNOW YOU
WERE AWARE OF OUR ROLE IN THAT
PROCESS SO EACH YEAR WE TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WE NEED TO FIND
NINE ONE ONE FOR THE STATE.
AS WELL AS UPGRADE BASED ON
LEGISLATIVE FIVE DIRECTION TO
NEXT GEN I'M ON ONE WE COME UP
WITH OUR PROPOSED BUDGET.
REVIEWED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND APPROVED AND GOES TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROCESS.
AT THAT POINT ONCE THE THE BILL
IS IS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
PASSED THE SETS ARE PRO RATIONS
NUMBER.
THAT NUMBER COMES BACK TO ME AND
THAT'S THE BASELINE IN THIS
LEGISLATION BY WHICH WE SET THE
FEE. FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR SO
WE CANNOT COLLECT MORE THAN THAT
APPROPRIATED AMOUNTS TO TAKE
THAT APPROPRIATE AMOUNT.
COMPARED TO THE NUMBER OF ACCESS
LINES THAT ARE REPORTED BY ALL
THE CARRIERS.
AND THEN IT'S JUST SIMPLE MATH
TO CALCULATE HOW MUCH THE FEE
NEEDS TO BE ASSESSED ON A
MONTHLY BASIS.
IN ORDER TO GENERATE THE REVENUE
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
AND THAT FEE IS PASSED BACK OVER
TO CD TFA.
WHO ESTABLISHES THE FEE FOR THE
UPCOMING YEAR SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF CHECKS AND BALANCES IN
THIS PROCESS A AND A AND ALONG
THE WAY?
IN OUR NEXT YEAR WILL BE BACK
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT LEVEL IS
IS SET APPROPRIATELY.
THE OTHER CHANGE IN THE
LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR.
WAS.
WE WE DEFINE.
THE ALL THE NINE ONE FEES ALL
FEES ARE SO SHE WOULD NINE ONE
INSIDE THIS REVENUE TAX CODE.
FOR NINE ONE THE LINKAGES TO
OTHER PIECES OF REVENUE AND TAX
CODE -- SECTIONS JUST TO MAKE IT
CLEAN IF IT'S NINE ONE IT'S IN
THE EMERGENCY TELEPHONE
SURCHARGE USERS ACT OR THE STE
WHICH GOES INTO THE STATE
EMERGENCY TELEPHONE NUMBER
ACCOUNT OR SET NOT.
AND THEN FINALLY -- WE AN
INCREASE THE AND WE WE DEFINE
NEXT AND I'M A ONE IN SUCH A WAY.
THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE THE
INFORMATION THAT'S IN NEXT GEN
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM. FOR ALERT
MORNINGS SO YOU'LL SEE THAT
DEFINITIONS EXPANDED ON THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING A STATEWIDE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM THAT'S
CAPABLEOF DELIVERING A LEARNED
WARNINGS IS.
OBVIOUSLY VERY RELEVANT IN THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE GOING ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND SO THIS
DEFINITION MAKE SURE THAT NEXT
GEN I'M ONE CAN SUPPORT THAT.
IT DOESN'T IMPACT THE LOCAL
AUTHORITIES -- ABILITY TO SEND
AN ALERT MORNING THAT'S A
DIFFERENT PROCESS IS JUST A
COMMON TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM. FOR
THAT.
AND THE OTHER THING WE WANTED TO
MENTION IS -- THE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES THIS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET US
THROUGH THE END OF THIS YEAR AND
INTO NEXT YEAR.
BUT ONE TO MENTION THAT.
WHILE THESE ONE TIME FUNDING --
INCREASES ARE HELPFUL TO GET US
THROUGH THESE INTERIM STEPS WILL
REALLY NEED IS A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MODEL.
WE MANAGE MULTIPLE CONTRACTS
THAT GO OVER MULTIPLE YEARS --
SOME TEN YEARS AND L<c.cyan>G.</c>
SO HAVING A YEAR TO YEAR FUNDING
MECHANISM TO SUPPORT A TEN YEAR
CONTRACT.
IS VERY CHALLENGING FOR THE
PROGRAM WHEN YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU
ENTER INTO A CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT AND AND YOU'RE NOT
SURE THE FINDINGS THERE SO.
HISTORICALLY THE SET IN A FUND
HAS BEEN A A FEE.
AND IT HAS SUPPORTED NINE ONE
ONE FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
HAS PROVEN TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE FUNDING MODELS THAT WE
HAVE.
AND SO THAT'S WHERE THIS -- NEW
FUNDING MODEL FOCUSES ON
ESTABLISHING A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE MODEL.
WITH THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE FOR US.
I'M BEFORE SEE IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION -- AS WE SPEAK THE
GOVERNOR IS PRESENTING HIS MAY
REVISION [inaudible]
I'M.
WILL THERE BE A ARE YOU -- DO
YOU HAVE THE INFORMATION OF
WHETHER WE WILL BE RECEIVING A
CHANGE IN THIS.
ITEM WITH THE MAY REVISION.
I'M SURE STEVEN BANDS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO THERE'S
NO UPDATE TO THIS PROPOSAL THE
MAYOR VISION.
WE HAD THE ITEM KEY DOES HOLD
OPEN AND IN THE NOT ASSUMING
THAT THERE WOULD BE BUT THAT IT
WAS ALWAYS A POSSIBILITY.
I'M.
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A THERE ARE.
IS IN OUR STAFF REPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES REQUEST I'M GOING ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
STATE EMERGENCY TELEPHONE NUMBER
ACCOUNT AND SIX POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT.
THE IMPLEMENTATION ONGOING
WORKLOAD WHAT'S THE COST OF THE
SIX POSITIONS.
THAT NUMBER IN FRONT OF YOU.
I COULD GO ON LOOKING MORE
DETAIL -- JUST OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD MY RECOLLECTION IS THE
MILLION DOLLARS IS THE COST OF
THE SIX POSITIONS BUT I I COULD
DOUBLE CHECK THAT FOR YOU SORRY
A RECENT TO THE ASSIGNMENT AND
SO -- WHAT'S FRESH OFF TOP MY
MIND MAY NOT BE PERFECT
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
WE CASTING THE FEE FROM A
PERCENTAGE RATE SURCHARGE TO A
FLAT RATE FEE.
WHAT'S THE AVERAGE FLAT RATE FEE
BASED ON THE PERCENTAGE THAT WAS
AT SIXTY CENTS IS A NINETY CENT.
YEAH SO THAT THAT'S A REALLY
INTERESTING QUESTION SO.
RIGHT NOW THE FEE AS SET BASED
ON INTRASTATE VOICE REVENUE --
AND SO THAT VARIES FROM.
THE CALCULATION OF THE REVENUE
BROUGHT IN WHETHER IT'S WIRELINE
WIRELESS VOICE OVER IP.
OR MOBILE PREPAID AND SO EACH OF
THOSE REVENUE STREAMS HAVE A
DIFFERENT PORTION ALLOCATED TO
VOICE.
AND DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE FROM
THE NUMBERS THE EXACT RATES BUT
WHAT WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
WIRELINE PAYS A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT.
IF YOU HAVE A HARD LINE WIRELINE
PHONE INTO YOUR HOME.
THAT'S MAJORITY VOICE IS WHAT
YOU'RE PAYING FOR AND SO YOU'RE
PAYING A DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT.
COMPARED TO WIRELESS WHERE THE
BULK OF THE REVENUE ASSOCIATED
WITH A WIRELESS BILL IS REALLY
FOR DATA.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR WIRELESS
BUILD REGARDLESS OF CARRIER.
VOICES ALMOST FREE AND IT'S A
VERY SMALL PORTION OF THE
OVERALL BILL THAT'S REALLY
WHAT'S CAUSING THE DECLINE IN
REVENUE.
THE BULK OF OUR USERS ARE PAYING
THE SMALLEST.
PERCENTAGE OF OF THE OVERALL
FEES SO 80% ROUGHLY OF OUR NINE
ONE CALLS COME FROM WIRELESS
DEVICES.
YET THE REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE WIRELESS USERS IS THE
LOWEST OF THE THREE CATS.
THE FOUR CATEGORIES CENTER IN
THERE AND WHAT THIS PROPOSAL
DOES THE IS IT JUST ESTABLISH
THE MALL THE SAME SETS THE SAME
EXACT RATE.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU'RE
WIRELINE USER OF VOICE OVER IP
USER WIRELESS USER OUR MOBILE
PREPAID.
THIS IS ALSO THE SAME SAME MODEL
THAT'S USED IN EVERY OTHER STATE.
WE'VE DONE AN ANALYSIS OF ALL
THE OTHER STATES ARE DOING THIS
AND IT'S THE SAME. TWO NOTABLE
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT BUT PRETTY
MUCH EVERYBODY'S IN THE SAME
FLAT FEE MODEL.
IS THAT ENSURE QUESTION
[inaudible]
NO.
I'M SO THE TRIAL DIFFERENTLY
THAN.
IF YOU HAVE A VOICE [inaudible]
YOU'RE PAYING [inaudible]
A NICKEL.
SO NOTHING YET SO THE NUMBERS
THAT I HAVE ARE ONLY ESTIMATES
SO IF IF YOU'RE HAPPY WITH SOME
SOME ROUGH ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
ESTIMATES WE CAN GIVE YOU THOSE
SO.
WIRELINE NUMBERS ARE ROUGHLY.
TWENTY SEVEN CENTS WE THINK
BASED ON THE NUMBERS WE HAVE
ACCESS -- TO VOICE OVER IP IS
PROBABLY LESS THAN FIVE CENTS
AND WIRELESS IS A LITTLE BIT
OVER FIVE CENTS AND AGAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE DATA
TO GIVE YOU A DEFINITIVE NUMBER
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A
DISPROPORTIONATE.
LEVEL IN AND HOW IT'S
DISTRIBUTED TODAY SO HOPEFULLY
THAT'S HELPFUL AGAIN.
ROUGH ORDER OF MAGNITUDE NUMBERS
BASED ON OUR ESTIMATES AN
INCREASE OF FOUR THOUSAND FORTY
TIMES RIGHT I MEAN THIS IS A
REFER SOMEONE ON WIRELESS AVOID
THEY'RE GONNA GET A WE'RE GONNA
SEE SOMETHING IN THEIR BILL.
SO THERE WILL BE A DIFFERENCE
BUT IT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE YOU'RE NOT
GONNA SEE A SIX DOLLAR INCREASE
PER MONTH.
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING
LESS THAN THE CUP OF THE PRICE
OF A CUP OF COFFEE. FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR TO GET A SUSTAINABLE
NINE ONE PROGRAM RIGHT IN -- AND
IN THE BOTTOM LINE IS AS AS
MITCH SAID.
THE REVENUES WE BRING AND JUST
SIMPLY DON'T SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW IT IF IF THERE WAS
ANOTHER WAY -- WE YOU KNOW WE
WOULD BE ALL FOR IT BUT AND WE
NEED A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE. FOR NINE ONE ONE NINE
ONE FAILS LIVES ARE AT RISK AND
WE WE JUST SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW
NINE ONE FAIL.
YOU'VE HAD A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM OF
PEOPLE TRANSFERRED FROM HARD
LINES TO WIRELESS.
AND THIS BEEN GOING ON FOR WHAT
THIRTY YEARS.
AND SO NOW WE'RE FINALLY
REACTING AND WE'RE GOING FROM A
NICKEL TO EIGHTY CENTS AS
OPPOSED TO A NICKEL TO DRAW A
DIME. FIFTEEN TO TWENTY RAISING
IN OVERTIME SO THIS IS JUST
GONNA REQUIRED TWO THIRDS VOTE
MANAGER.
BUT THIS BE CONSIDERED A TAX
INCREASE.
YES THE TRAILER BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS.
ALRIGHT WE'RE BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE LAST YEAR.
I JUST WANNA MAKE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION WHILE THE TRAILER
BILL ALLOWS A RANGE OF ZERO TO
EIGHTY IT WILL NOT BE SET AT
EIGHTY THE RANGE THAT SAT IS
GOING TO BE DEPENDENT UPON THE
APPROPRIATION THAT'S GIVEN TO
CALLOW YES BY.
NO BY BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY AS APPROVED BY THE AS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND OUR ESTIMATES ARE
PATIENT IT'S UP TO NOT TO EXCEED
BUT IT WRECKED BUT IT WOULD NOT.
IN WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING IT
WOULD NOT UNLESS WE WERE TO
APPROPRIATE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IT WOULD NOT GO UP TO
THAT FOR PER CELLULAR USER
THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT --
AND WHAT IT THE SP IS IT MORE-ACCURATE OR CAN YOU.
COULD YOU. FIVE GIVE US SOME
SOME SENSE THAT IT WOULD BE.
MORE ON THE BORDER OF THAT WHAT
IS WHAT THE SO USER WOULD
EXPERIENCE IF WE WERE TO APPROVE
THIS WOULD BE MORE ON THE ORDER
OF WHAT THE HARD LINE.
USER IS NOW PAYING.
SO IF I COULD HAVE.
SO BASED ON THE CURRENT --
PROPOSED APPROPRIATION LEVEL THE
ESTIMATE IS THAT THE FEE WOULD
INITIALLY BE SET IN THE THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR CENTS RANGE --
AND I COULD SAY LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
LOOKINGAT MY OWN PERSONAL CELL
PHONE BILL I PAY NINE CENTS A
MONTH -- FOR NINE ONE ONE SO FOR
ME IT WOULD GO FROM NINE CENTS
TO THIRTY THREE CENTS -- IS THE
CURRENT ESTIMATE.
OF THE IMPACT AT THIS POINT.
CONTINUE TO OUR NORTH I THINK
THAT'S IT I'M I'M JUST.
YOU KNOW WE GOT A CONTACT HERE
IN A WATER TAX THERE AND BEFORE
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A CUP OF
COFFEE ANYMORE IT'S A GALLON.
AND SO I JUST WANNA.
BUT IF RESPECT.
THANK WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE TO
AND AND YOUR CONCERN AND IF WE
HAD ANOTHER WAY -- TO TO DO THIS
WE WOULD CERTAINLY BE MINIMAL
AYE AYE I CAN TELL YOU THAT WERE.
NOW WE WERE WERE NOT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH REVENUE TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM.
AND IT IS TO CRITICAL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY THE THE START POINT
FOR EVERYTHING WE DO.
AND FOR EVERY EMERGENCY AND AS
MUCH SAID FIVE NINE ONE FAILS
LIVES -- FIVE SERVER IN JEOPARDY
AND SO -- IN.
WE'VE WE'VE GOT A SUPPORT.
I'M NOT ARGUING THAT POINT --
THE ISSUE IS AT A BUDGET IS A
REFLECTION OF PRIORITIES.
AND SO WE HAVE STILL TWENTY ONE
AND A HALF BILLION OF SURPLUS AS
THE TERM.
BEING USED.
AND SO.
WHY IS?
A GOOD PORTION OF THAT OR A
PORTION OF THAT.
BUT IN TO HELP YOU THAT BEING
PAYS DOWN AND THEN YOUR RATES
BEING PHASED IN.
OVER TIME SO YOU MEET YOUR HAPPY.
YOU KNOW GOAL SOMEWHERE OUT
THERE IN THE FUTURE YOU HAVE A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT'S MORE
PREDICTABLE -- BUT I'M I'M JUST
CONCERNED.
BECAUSE EVEN THE MEDIA IS
ALREADY SAYING HOW DO YOU DO A%
TAX INCREASE WHEN YOU'VE GOT A
TWENTY ONE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO WE'RE ALL GONNA HAVE TO DEAL
WITH AND I JUST WANTED.
TO BROUGHT A LITTLE BIT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE THANK YOU
MATTER.
IF I COULD JUST CLARIFY TO YOUR
FIRST QUESTION I DO HAVE
CONFIRMATION THE MILLION DOLLARS
IS THE ON GOING COSTS THE SIX
POSITIONS [inaudible]
YEAH.
IN TO CERTAIN EXTENT WE ARE
BOUNCING THAT ONE TIME USE
THAT'S WITH A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR TRANSFER IS IS A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TRANSFER SO THAT WE
CAN.
HELP WITH THAT -- STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT BUT ALSO SOME OF THE ONE
TIME COSTS FOR THE SWITCH. TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF THE FEE
IF WE DIDN'T DO THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR TRANSFER THIS
YEAR.
THEN THE THIRTY THREE CENTS THAT
I WAS CITING EARLIER IS OUR
CURRENT ESTIMATE WOULD OBVIOUSLY
GO UP BECAUSE WE HAVE TO COVER --
BASICALLY PAYING BACK WHATEVER
SORT OF GENERAL FUND ON WE DID.
TO TO BRIDGE THE GAP.
WE ARE WE ARE USING THE ONE TIME.
THE SURPLUS IS THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW TO HELP OUT WITH THIS
PROGRAM AS WELL [inaudible]
I'M.
I APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS
BECAUSE IT WAS.
NOT FULLY CLEAR FROM THE ITEM
WHAT THE ACTUAL IMPACT.
FOR CELLULAR USER WOULD BE.
AND THE WIRELESS USER HOWEVER WE
WANT TO DESCRIBE IT AND YOU KNOW
I EIGHT I WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
OUR ACTING LAST YEAR BECAUSE I
DON'T RECALL RIGHT NOW WHETHER
IT WOULD HAVE -- RESULTED IN A A
THIRTY THREE CENTS SAID.
INCREASE TO THE PER USER OR
WHATEVER WHETHER IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN SLIGHTLY LOWER SO THAT THEN
YOU KNOW WE COULD HAVE HAD THAT
MORE.
GRADUATED AS PRE DATED AS YOUR
DESCRIBING.
BUT I I KNOW I TOTALLY
APPRECIATE THE POINT THAT YES WE
HAVE.
WE WE HAVE MORE REVENUES NOW
THEN THE BUDGET THAT'S PROPOSED.
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THESE ON
GOING EXPENSES.
AND IT'S ONE OF THESE WHERE WE
ARE WE ARE GOING TO BE TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN FOR THE NEXT FOREVER.
UNTIL COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES POP IN DEPENDENT ON
THESE TECHNOLOGIES FOR OUR
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND WITH THE
DEATHS IN THE FIRES.
OF LAST YEAR.
AND JUST WITH HOW MUCH I KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS NINE ONE
ONE SERVICE IS.
I FEEL LIKE QUEEN -- IT'S HARD
BUT WE NEED TO BITE THE BULLET
AND I AND GET DE.
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SUSTAINABLE FINDING.
AND WHILE CERTAINLY WE COULD USE
SOME OF OUR SURPLUS FOR THAT
PURPOSE -- IT EVENTUALLY WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY THIS AND
THERE ARE OTHER DEBTS IN OTHERS
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY ONE TIME
ONLY TYPE OF USES THAT.
WHILE I'M A IT OBVIOUSLY NOT THE
GOVERNOR AND I WILL NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY OPINE ON WHAT MIGHT
BE THE BEST.
THE ONE TIME USES OF THAT EXTRA
MONEY WE HAVE SINCE THIS IS AN
ON GOING I'M COMFORTABLE.
WITH ACTING ON IT AND THE ITEM
WAS ON HELD OPEN OR IN MARCH AND
DESIGNATED IS HELD OPEN.
IN ANTICIPATION THAT THERE MIGHT
BE AN ADJUSTMENT MADE ME REVISED
BUT SINCE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS INDICATED.
THAT THERE WOULDN'T BE SUCH
THERE.
THERE IS NOT.
SUCH AN ADJUSTMENT IN THE MAY
REVISE.
AND BASICALLY WE WOULD JUST HAVE
THIS VERY SAME ITEM BEFORE US
AGAIN NEXT WEEK.
I'M I'M GOING TO RECOMMEND THAT
WE VOTE ON IT [inaudible]
TODAY -- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
SERVER -- QUESTION [inaudible]
RIGHT SO.
WE I HAVE A MOTION. TO A CERTAIN
THE ITEM AS WRITTEN -- AND LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
FOR DONALD.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF IT FOR US.
WITNESSES ELOQUENTLY SAID. NINE
ONE ONE IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES --
WE HAVE HE DUBIOUS DISTINCTION
OF BEING AMONG THE MORE
VULNERABLE -- TARGETS MERGING
SEE SERVICES -- PORTING JUSTICE
SICK LAST YEAR -- AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENT.
TAKES PLACE ON A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS.
ONCE EVERY EIGHT EIGHT THIS IS A
HIGH PRIORITY WITH US WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF RUBBER TO GO
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AND ALSO PENSION HERE -- FOR MY
COLLEAGUE OVER AT THE ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA -- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS TRAILER BILL.
QUITE FRANKLY WE THINK IT'S LONG
OVERDUE -- AND WE THINK THAT THE
NINE ONE SYSTEM I REALLY NEEDS A
BILL LIKE THIS FOR THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY.
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH WILL --
WHICH WILL SAVE LIVES IN THE
FUTURE SO -- WITHOUT -- WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING INGRID DRAWN SURE
HAVE MONO COUNTY MEMBER OF THE
NINE ONE ADVISER BLURRED.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THIS TRAILER BILL AS A PROVIDER
OF NINE ONE ONE SERVICES THE AND
RECEIVER.
AND IN A PRIOR LIFE ACTUALLY
ANSWERING.
NINE ONE DOWN IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF NINE ONE ONE AND
ENHANCING THE RESILIENCY.
OF OUR NINE ONE SYSTEM WHICH IS.
A LEGACY SYSTEM THAT IS OUTDATED
AND OUTMODED AND HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH TECHNOLOGY AND THIS
REVISION OF THE FUNDING STREAM
WILL BRING CALIFORNIA IN LINE
WITH WHAT.
NEARLY EVERY OTHER STATE DOES
AND OTHER CHEAPER COST AND AT
WHAT ANY OTHER STATE DOES.
AND I STRONGLY URGE.
I'M SURE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR
HAVING ME DAVID DUNCAN MD I'M
EMERGENCY POSITION I'M NOT FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS I'VE BEEN
NEMS MEDICAL DIRECTOR FIFTEEN
YEARS.
I'M HERE TO LEVY STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THREE ORGANIZATIONS
I'M OFF BUYERS MEDICAL DIRECTOR
WE WOULD LIKE TO LEVEES OR I'M
ALSO CAL STAR REACHES.
A MEDICAL DIRECTOR ON BEHALF OF
THAT ORGANIZATION AND THE
NATIONAL OVERSEEING ORGANIZATION
FOR THOSE TWO WHICH NOW INCLUDES
A A MORE.
ALL THE GM AREN'T WE ALSO LEVY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROVISION TO THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM.
AND THEN ON BEHALF OF EM D. A C.
M. DOC WHICH IS THE STATE'S.
YEAH MASS MEDICAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FOR ALL COUNTIES IN
THE STATE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE NINE ONE
ONE REVISION.
AS LET ME HEAR ANY CELLS THANK
YOU UP.
AS AN EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN.
THIS IS IN MY OPINION THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT MEDICAL DEVICE
THAT WE BRING TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT.
IN SOME WAYS I FEEL LIKE I'M
STRAPPED USING PENICILLIN IS MY
ONLY ANTIBIOTIC WITH THE CURRENT
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM AND I REALLY
NEED TO UPGRADE THIS IF I'M
GOING TO SAVE LIVES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JESSICA SEVEN TEN
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
AND WE THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ESPINASSE
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
CHRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE SENATE TRAILER BILL.
THE MANAGER MY NAME'S MICHAEL
GLAD FROM THE FIRE CHIEF WITH
QASIM THIS FIRE DEPARTMENT IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
VISITING CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN MENTIONED --
NUMEROUS TIMES -- THIS MORNING
ARE A ONE IS THE LIFELINE GIVING
THE ABILITY -- FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO BE ABLE TO SEEK OUT HELP WHEN
THEY NEED IT MOST RIGHT NOW OUR
SYSTEM IS BASICALLY BEING.
SUBSIDIZED AND FUNDED BY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION.
THE SENIOR CITIZENS AND PEOPLE
LIVING IN RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
RIPPE THE PROMINENT OWNERS OF
LAND LINE.
TELEPHONE STAND THAT WE RELY ON
THIS IS NO G. 80% OF CELLULAR
CALLS AND BE ABLE TO HAVE A
SYSTEM TO SUPPORT AND CARRIED
FORWARD.
WITH THAT -- WE WE WE AND WAS
FULL SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE YOU
TO VOTE I ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BUT I'M TERM MEMBER SEAN RUN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY NINE ONE ONE
COALITION AS WELL AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
ENTIRE PROFESSION WHO OF PLACE
THIS IS A PRIORITY IT'S KEY TO
THE INTEGRITY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OR JUST.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA MOM WE HAVE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
TRAILER BILL OF IN DEFENSE OF
THE LEGACY SYSTEM THAT WON'T
EVEN SURVIVE WITHOUT THE ECTION
AND ALSO WE ARE MISSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO SAVE LIVES.
BY NOT BEING ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE SO WE URGE YOUR
ADOPTION.
MADAM CHAIR TERRY MCHALE WITH
ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE WE ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
WE ARE ALSO HOPEFUL WILL BE
ENOUGH FIREFIGHTERS TO RESPOND
TO THE CALL.
OUR FIREFIGHTERS WERE OUT THERE
FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS AT A TIME
WITHOUT A BREAK SO -- PLEASE
REMEMBER THAT WHEN WE GET THESE
CALLS SOMEONE HAS TO ANSWER.
AND WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED FEWER.
FIREFIGHTERS HIRED FOR THIS
SEASON AND WE HAD LAST YEAR.
SO WHAT WE WANT PREVENTION AND
WE WANT RESPONSE LET'S NOT
FORGET IT THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE ON THE GROUND TO DO THE JOB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY SYSTEM.
ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION
ANYMORE COMMON OR QUESTIONS BY
COLLEAGUES CERTAINLY CENTER ORE
LEFT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
THIS CAME UP LAST YEAR IN AND I
I WORK AS BEST AS I COULD WITH --
E. S..
AND WITH REGINALD SALVADOR THE
TIME WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND SAID LET ME HELP YOU.
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE YOU'LL
IMPLEMENT THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
GOING. TO TAKE TO GET SO
CRITICAL AND THEN YOU WAIT AND
YOU WAIT AND YOU WAIT AND YOU
WAIT AND YOU SAY OKAY.
YOU'RE WATCHING THE TRENDS FOR
HER.
AND THEN AND THEN AND THEN YOU
JUST DO THIS MASSIVE INCREASE --
I YOU KNOW IT WHEN IT REFLECTS
POOR MANAGEMENT TO ITS IT IT.
IT PUTS A BURDEN ON TAXPAYERS OR
IS.
IT WE WE HAD A WITH SP ONE IT'S
LIKE.
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING HAD BEEN
HELP FLAT FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
EVEN THOUGH GAS TAXES WERE WERE
RISING AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE HAVE.
BECAUSE ROADS ARE BAD BILL NOW
SOMEONE ELSE HAS TO PAY.
NOW IT'S A GAS TAX IN.
AND AND SO I I'M JUST REBELLING
MADAM CHAIR BECAUSE I I WANTED
TO HELP BY I REACHED OUT.
AND AND AND AND THERE ARE WAYS
TO PHASE IT IN AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING WHEN THERE
IS A BUDGET SURPLUS THAT WORDS.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE ELSE LIKE DID
THAT WORK.
SO IT'S JUST IT'S JUST HARD TO
COMMUNICATE [inaudible]
THE CONSTITUENTS -- AND SO.
I'M A LITTLE FRUSTRATED --
MANAGER BECAUSE I I I HAVE I
HAVE BEEN SINCE REALLY TRYING ON
THIS AND I I'VE BEEN AVAILABLE.
GOT FILE MY BIG FILE MY DESK OF
ALL RESEARCH.
SO I'LL BE A NOTE TODAY.
IS THAT BECAUSE OF THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN DONE A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY -- WITH A LITTLE.
BETTER GRADUATION INTO THE
PROGRAM -- IT BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE 20% THAT
SOMEHOW BARELY CAN AFFORD A
PHONE OR THE REST O THE
NECESSITIES OF LIFE.
THAT WAS A I WAS A PROP.
THERE'S REGINALD NOW THANK YOU I
MEAN.
IN MY IN MY NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
IS THIS A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
SIDE OF MY HEAD COLLEGES CALVET
WE SO MUCH LOVE YOU HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION THE ONE THING
ADMINISTRATION IS ON WHERE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHAT'S HAVE -- A ROLL CALL ON
THE MOTION.
UNDER SKINNER FIVE OR MORE LAW
[inaudible]
UNDER ABOUT.
RIGHT SO.
THAT HAVE MOTION PASSES BUT I'D
LIKE TO DO NOW IS A MOTION ON
THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS IT'S ISSUE
ONE TWO AND THREE WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO AN INDIVIDUAL.
MOST.
SERVICE WE GOT EM.
THIS IS ON YES.
RIGHT -- SIX NINE ZERO POLICIES
ISSUE ONE TWO AND THREE OF A
CONTRITION OUR A A MOVIE ITEMS.
ALRIGHT SO WE NOW HAVE A MOTION
ON BY IT ISSUE ONE TWO AND THREE
OF OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES --
SIX NINE NO LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE WE
PROCEED WITH OUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NINE WILL
PROCEED WITH THE VOTE.
UNDER SKINNER.
MARLA BY REBEL.
RIGHT SO THEN -- BECAUSE I KNOW
SOME FOLKS HAVE TO LEAVE WE I
WANTED TO SWITCH JUST QUICKLY.
TO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
FINE -- OUR NEXT AGENDA SO I'M
TAKING A LITTLE OUT OF ORDER --
IT'S PART BE.
ITS JUDICIAL BRANCH.
AND THEY ARE -- UNDER ZERO TWO
FIVE ZERO AND IT'S ISSUE ONE
THROUGH TWELVE AND THEIR VOTE
ONLY.
AND THE VOTES ARE IS LISTED IN
OUR COMMITTEE AGENDA.
SO IF I COULD GET ONE MOTION ON
THOSE.
I'D APPRECIATE IT A MOVE ON MOVE
ALL THE ISSUES EXCEPT FOR NUMBER.
NINE SEPARATE OVERNIGHT SO WE
PULL THAT OUT THESE ALRIGHT SO
THEN WE WOULD HAVE WE HAVE A
MOTION NOW.
FINE IT'S ZERO TWO FIFTY
JUDICIAL BRANCH ISSUES ONE
THROUGH EIGHT AND THEN ISSUE TEN
ELEVEN AND TWELVE PROVE AS THE
IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT BEFORE WE
TAKE A VOTE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING.
NINE WE ARE VOTING AGAIN.
FIND ITEMS.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT OF JUDICIAL BRANCH
BUT ONLY AN ITEM TEN ELEVEN AND
TWELVE BROKAW.
UNDER SKINNER HI AND MARLA.
I REBEL.
NOW WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO --
CENTER MORE LACKEY IS RETURNED
TO NOT DISCUSSED DISCO AT THE
MOMENT WE'LL DO IT WHEN WE GO
BACK -- TO PART B..
BUT I WILL TAKE AN ITEM.
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
SPRING CAPITAL OUTLAYS THAT
ISSUE THIRTEEN THAT'S A VOTE
ONLY TWO I HAVE A MOTION ON THAT.
ONE GOT A MOTION IS THERE ANY OF
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT ITEM.
NO OKAY THOUGHT THE FOLKS
GETTING UP MY TO BE SPEAKING ON
THAT OKAY THEY'RE NOT SO WE'LL
DO A ROLL CALL.
THIS IS ISSUE THIRTEEN
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION.
SPRING CAPITAL OUTLAYS
UNDERSTAND BY.
MARLA.
CENTER ABOUT.
A GREAT NOW WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
PARTY GO BACK TO PART EIGHT AND
WE'RE GONNA START ON LEGISLATIVE
PROS PROPOSALS.
AND WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS READ
EACH INDIVIDUALLY AND AFTER I
READ THE MOMENT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE ITEM.
THE INDIVIDUAL ITEM AND ALLOW IT
TO HAPPEN AND IF -- IN MY
INTENTION IS TO LEAVE THOSE
ITEMS OPEN -- BUT WE WILL ALLOW
THERE TO BE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
BEFORE I START TO READ THOSE I
AM GOING TO ASK.
OUR SPECIAL SERVICES STAFF -- IF
HE AT I AM GOING TO USE A PODIUM
NOW SO I CAN STAND IN CHAIR THE
MEETING.
BECAUSE IT IS MUCH BETTER ON MY
BACK AND I DO NOT WANT TO HAVE
AT THE END OF THIS BUDGET
PROCESS -- HAVE MY BACK GO OUT
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PODIUM
BROUGHT UP AND THEN I'LL START
READING THE LEGISLATIVE ITEMS
WHICH ARE ON THE AGENDA PART A
STARTING WITH ISSUE
.
FIVE NOW IT SIGN IT.
OKAY SO THE FIRST ITEM.
IS A REQUEST FOR SCHOOL SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS WITH EMERGENCY
FIRST RESPONDERS AND IT'S A I
REQUEST FOR FIVE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND IS THERE ANY --
PUBLIC THAT WANTED TO SPEAK TO
THAT.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NINE THE NEXT
ITEM ISSUE.
SIX IS A FIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
OR TO IN CREASE SECURITY AT
CALIFORNIA NON PROFITS.
I'M IT IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR SOME TIME THE STATE
IS PROVIDED.
BY ABOUT FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
IN THE PAST ONCE ONLY HALF A
MILLION AND THIS REQUEST WOULD
BE -- TO INCREASE IT TO FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR THIS UPCOMING BUDGET
YEAR ONE TIME ONLY.
THERE ANYONE WOULD SPEAK TO THAT --
ON BEHALF OF G. PACK IN SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM WE WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
INCLUDING THIS IN THE MAY
REVISED.
THE RESET TOXIN PITTSBURG SAN
DIEGO AND NEW ZEALAND
UNFORTUNATELY HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
TO FUND THIS PROGRAM WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
ME REVISED PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND CERTAINLY -- SENATOR BILL IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON ANY OF THESE YOU
ARE WELCOME.
TO AND ASK THEM.
ALRIGHT SO ISSUE.
SEVEN IS OF A REQUEST FOR TWELVE
MILLION TO HELP FIND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND HAZARD
MITIGATION. FOR THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
OUR YES PUBLIC COMMENT AND THE
OVER UNDER WITH TRUE STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
THIS ONE TIME FUNDING OF TWELVE
MILLION. FOR OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND HAZARD
MITIGATION EFFORTS IN THE CITY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU.
IN CENTER ROAD ONE MAKE A
COMMENT.
SO THEN WE'LL GO TO ISSUE.
EIGHT AND THIS IS A ON GOING
THIRTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND.
REQUEST FOR MODERNIZING AND
IMPROVING [inaudible]
LOCATOR TECHNOLOGIES THAT WOULD
I GIVE MORE EFFICIENT RESOURCE
DEPLOYMENT WOULD UPGRADE
ANTIQUATED SYSTEMS.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THAT
ITEM.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTIE BELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RUSSELL
NOVAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- INSTRUCTS ORDER.
ALLOWING OUR FIRST RESPONDERS BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH EACH
OTHER OUT IN THE FIELD TO SAVE
LIVES [inaudible]
HANK YOU.
OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE THE ISSUE.
NINE WHICH IS TWENTY THREE
MILLION OR TWENTY THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
REQUEST FOR ONE TIME. TO SUPPORT
A NORTH STATE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAINING AND EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER.
THAT WOULD BE IN A YUBA CITY.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS WILLIAM
FORM WITH THE YUBA CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE CHAIRPERSON FOR STATE
ELLIE PC REGION THREE AND ALSO
ON THE STATE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
COMMISSION.
WE'RE HERE TODAY YUBA CITY'S
BEEN THE LEAD AGENCY ON THIS
PROJECT WORKING WITH OUR
REGIONAL.
PARTNERS.
WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM. SIXTY SIX
AGENCIES REPRESENTING TWENTY
COUNTIES IN THE NORTH STATE.
WE'RE LOOKING TO DO THIS BECAUSE%
THE COST OF SENDING OUR PEOPLE
DOWN.
FOR REQUIRED ESSENTIAL TRAINING
IS BECOMING A FINANCIAL BURDEN.
FOR ALL OVER THE AGENCIES.
SAN PEOPLE'S BAKERSFIELD OR SAN
LUIS OBISPO.
IT ISN'T WORKING IN A RETURN --
DEALS WITH THE OVERTIME AND
BACKFILL ISSUES THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
ARE HAVING TO DEAL WITH -- THIS
FACILITY WILL BE A TOP NOTCH
FACILITY THAT WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING NOT JUST FOR YOU FOR
THE LOCAL FIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT'LL BE ABLE FOR STATE AGENCIES
FEDERAL AGENCIES ANYTHING IN
THAT ARE WORKING IN THAT AREA.
I HAVE SOME OTHER DISH
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS TURN IT
OVER TO THEM.
VERY QUICKLY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELIZABETH HAS BEEN --
SOME BEHALF OF THE COLUSA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS FUNDING.
CARE TO RESERVATIONS JOHN
SHALLOW AT SOME OF THE SUTTER
COUNTY FIRE CHIEF.
AND OPERATIONAL AREA COORDINATOR --
FOR YES RESPONSES OUT OF THE
COUNTY.
I'M HERE IN TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS -- TRAINING CENTER --
PRIMARILY THIS IS A GREAT
ADDITION TO THE NORTH STATE FOR
THIS CAN BE FUNDED. TO HELP ALL
OF THE NOR STATE.
FIRE AGENCIES ALONG WITH -- OUR
PARTNERS IN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
THIS IS ALSO GOING TO BE USED AS
A PLACE FOR PRE POSITIONING FIRE
APPARATUS WITH THE NEW PRE
POSITIONING -- REMARK THAT HAS
COME OUT THROUGH OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES SO THIS WILL
BE IN ADDITION TO THAT AND WE
CAN BE ALSO BE USED TO ASSIST.
TIMES OF NEED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR ROBLIN INTO SHAPE
YUBA CITY.
I'M ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE SUB DISABILITY THE FACT THAT
IT DOES REGIONAL ALLIES AND
ALLOWS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO WORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES IT'S
A HUGE FINANCIAL SAVINGS FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE NORTH STATE TO
BRING IN AN AREA THAT SEVERELY.
UNDER.
UNDER A RESOURCE RIGHT NOW SO
PRESENTS A GREAT SILLY FOR US
AND I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS HERE
IN THE CITY.
BRENDA HOW SUTTER COUNTY OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
ITEM IT IS IT JUST MAKES SENSE
FOR THE NORTH PART OF THE STATE
PART OF OUR ROLE IS.
TO FACILITATE AND COORDINATE
SUPPORT FOR THESE TYPES OF
TRAINING SO THAT WERE BETTER TO
RESPOND.
IN A MORE REGIONAL FASHION SO
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SPREE.
DANA LANGLEY INTERIM CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY TO CITY AND
I JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS MATTER
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE -- ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF THAT ITEM ISSUE
[inaudible]
NINE ALL RIGHT.
ISSUE TEN WHICH IS A REQUEST.
FOR ONGOING TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND
[inaudible]
OR I'M.
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PREVENT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MADAM CHAIR NUMBER MELANIE
GRIFFITH CANTON OUGHT TO HURT
MEN ON BEHALF OF CAST OCEAN TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS HUMBLE
AUGMENTATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- V. TEN MILLION
ONGOING GRANT FUNDING IS GREAT
FOR RETRO ACTIVELY SERVING
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WHEN A CRIME HAS OCCURRED.
THIS TWO POINT FIVE AUGMENTATION
WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO HELP US
PRO ACTIVELY COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE STATE.
AND THANK YOU CHAIR FOR YOUR
HELP LAST YEAR.
ON A SIDE TO RISEN IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TEN MILLION ALONG
WITH THE ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION ON GOING THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS ARE SPEAKERS FOR THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ALL RIGHT THEN LET'S GO TO ISSUE
ELEVEN ENACT STATE REQUEST FORM
POINT. ZERO FIVE MILLION.
IN GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES EMERGENCY
SYSTEM.
OF RIGHT A WILDFIRE RESPONSE IN
VARIOUS OTHER THINGS AHEAD.
CHRISTINA GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA TO
STATE SUPPORT FOR THE FOUR POINT
OH FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
APPROPRIATION TO SUPPORT THE
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SEPARATE
DEVASTATING LOSS THAT RESULTED
IN PROPERTY DAMAGE DESTRUCTING
THOUSAND SUPPLIES BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENT SERVICES DUE TO THE
THOMAS FIRE.
WHICH WAS AT THE TIME THE
LARGEST WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
AFTER WEEKS OF WILDFIRES THE
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY CONTINUE TO
SUFFER DEVASTATING MUD SLIDES
WHICH CREATE A TREMENDOUS LOSS
AND RESULTED IN INFRASTRUCTURE
DAMAGE PROPERTY LOSS.
TELL IS THE COUNTY OF SANTA
BARBARA SEEKING FUNDING FOR
CREDIT CRITICAL NEEDS TO ENSURE
GREAT.
A GREATER RESILIENCE THE NEXT
TIME A DISASTER STRIKES THE ONE
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION THE LAND
MOBILE RADIO SYSTEMS ON THE
PUBLIC SAFETY MICROWAVE RADIO
SYSTEM.
I DURING THE FIRE AND DEBRIS
FLOWS THE COUNTY OF SANTA
BARBARA DISCOVERED
COMMUNICATIONS DAILY -- AND
EXISTING RADIO SYSTEMS THAT LEFT
FIRST RESPONDERS AND ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OTHER.
WITH EACH OTHER FROM CANYON TO
CANYON THE CURRENT RADIO SYSTEM
DID NOT WORK WITH THEM OR AGENCY
PERSONNEL DEPLOYED AND MULTIPLE
CANYONS WHICH CREATED MANY
SAFETY OBSTACLES FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
Là COMBAT BAUCOM ADDING THE
DEADLY WILDFIRES AND POSTING CAM.
THANK YOU AND FINALLY WE HAVE AN
ISSUE.
TWELVE WHICH IS.
A REQUEST FOR EIGHT MILLION.
I'M IN GENERAL FUND.
TO THAT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT THE PURCHASER FOR MOBILE
OPERATION SATELLITE EMERGENCY
SYSTEMS.
BUT THE SYSTEMS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER AND USED IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
I'M AND ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
ON A REGARDING THAT ITEM.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTY MAMA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
SPEAKING TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL LEVIN SIXTY
FIVE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
IN A JURISDICTION THAT HAS CAN.
PUT THIS EQUIPMENT TO USE
BECAUSE THE IN HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUPPORT TO
UTILIZE IT AND SUPPORT IT.
SO WE URGE YOUR ADOPTION TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RUSSELL
NOVAK AGAIN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
OF SO SESSION OF CALIFORNIA --
ALSO ITS EXPORT OF THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT.
SO ANY OTHER SPEAKERS ON OUT
ITEM OR ANY OF THE ITEMS WE
DON'T WITH PREVIOUSLY IN CASE
SOMEONE WASN'T IN THE ROOM.
OKAY I'M WE ARE HOLDING THEM
OPEN.
BUT APPRECIATE THOSE OF YOU WHO
CAME TO EXPRESS [inaudible]
YOUR I DIDN'T HEAR ANY
OPPOSITION SORT OF STRUCTURE
SUPPORT ARE THOSE ITEMS -- AND
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW GO
[inaudible]
WE WILL [inaudible]
INCLUDE.
OUR PART A WHICH IS TO DO WITH
THE OFFICE OF AN EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND WE WILL NOW MOVE.
TO OUR PART BE AGENDA.
I'M.
SO WE'LL HAVE STAFF CHANGING
HERE AT THE WE'LL HAVE STAFF
CHANGING HERE AT THE PODIUM.
AND FOR THIS AGENDA WE WILL --
BUT WE'RE GONNA START WITH THIS
CALL STAFF BEING BUT I'D BE THAT.
SENATOR MORE LACK.
I COULD HOLD IT HE'S GONNA
RETURN.
OKAY SO I SO IT'S NO WORRIES I
KNOW YES LEAVE AT TWELVE THIRTY
BUT I I THINK.
OUR ISSUE THIRTEEN WON'T
NECESSARILY TAKE ALL THE WAY
TILL TWELVE THIRTY SO WILL DEAL
WITH THE ISSUE THIRTEEN AND THEN
WILL RETURN TO THE SCOUT.
RIGHT SO ISSUE NINE WE'RE GONNA
HOLD OPEN FOR A BIT.
BUT WILL GO -- TO THE ITEM FIVE
TWO TWO FIVE BERMAN OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION ISSUE
THIRTEEN AND IT'S REGARDING THE
VARIOUS -- NO SORRY.
POLICIES ISSUE FOURTEEN FIVE TWO
TWO FIVE ISSUE.
FOURTEEN IN CAPITAL OUTLAYS FOR
CDC ARE AND WE WILL HAVE DEAN
BOARD.
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF SAUDI
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION AND
MANAGEMENT.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DEAN BORG REPRESENT
APARTMENT CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION -- THEIR TWO
ITEMS -- COULD HAVE SEPARATE
PROJECTS IN THIS ITEM THE FIRST
PROJECT IS LOCATED AT SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON -- THE
EXISTING HEATING AND HOT WATER
BOILER SYSTEM IT SANK WHEN DOES
NOT MEET CURRENT AIR QUALITY
REQUIREMENTS.
WE HAVE NOT FACED FINES YET
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN KEEPING THE
AIR QUALITY BOARD APPRISED OF
OUR WORK ON THIS PROJECT -- THE
FINES WOULD TOTAL TWELVE MILLION --
IF THEY WERE TO FIND US AND THAT
WOULD INCREASE BY ABOUT TWO
MILLION ANNUALLY. TO THE PROJECT
IN FRONT OF US IS --
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING TO REPLACE
EXISTING BOILERS AND THE NINETY
YEAR OLD BUILDING THE BOILERS
ARE LOCATED IN WITH THREE NEW
BOILERS IT'LL BE COMPLAIN WITH
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS A NEW
METAL BOILER BUILDING AND
NECESSARY BACKUP ELECTRICAL AND
FUEL STORAGE -- THE DESIGNS --
ARE UNDER REVIEW BY THE STATE
FARM MARSHALL SO -- PENDING
COMPLETION OF THE REVIEW WILL BE
READY TO GO TO BED LATER THIS
YEAR -- ADS.
ANY QUESTIONS ON ON THAT ITEM.
FROM WHAT I MIGHT DO WE HAD THEM.
WE HAD AS YOU MENTIONED TO
CAPITAL OUTLAY ITEMS WITHIN THIS
[inaudible]
ONE AGENDA ITEM.
BUT I THINK THE NEW BOILER.
I'M JUST IN JUST CONVERSING WITH
STAFF.
IT IS A NEW A CONTINUING PROJECT
SO I SEE NO REASON WHY NOT TO
CLOSE IT OUT RIGHT NOW.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THE LA OVER
FINANCE WOULD HAVE ANY COMMON
YEAH SO I THINK -- IF MY
COLLEAGUE IS WILLING WE WOULD
THEN ACT ON THIS AS REQUESTED.
B. M. BOILER PROJECT -- SAN
QUENTIN.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
OF PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
PROJECT.
SEEING NONE LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER MORE
LOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
OKAY NOW SO THAT PASSES.
WE WILL NOW GO TO BUT I
CERTAINLY WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN.
OR CENTER MORE LEX RETURN IF YOU
WANT TO ADD ON WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE SECOND PART OF ISSUE.
FOURTEEN WHICH IS THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ARE SO HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
ALSO KNOWN BY THE ACRONYM A
PICTURE IS -- THE DEPARTMENT'S
EFFORT IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
FEDERAL -- HEALTH CARE RECEIVER
TO IMPROVE OUTPATIENT HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
PRISON SYSTEM. SIX RANGE FROM --
PRIMARY CARE CLINICS ESPECIALLY
CARE CLINICS MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES AND
PHARMACIES.
OVERALL IT'S ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF
BOTH NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATION -- IN VERY COMPLEXITY
TO PRISON WITH AS MANY AS EIGHT
TO TEN INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS SOME
GOING SIMULTANEOUSLY OTHERS
WAITING FOR THE INITIAL PROJECTS
TO GET COMPLETED.
OVERALL STATEWIDE ARE
CONSTRUCTION COMPLETION SITS AT
70%.
OF THE TWENTY FIVE PRISONS ARE
FUNDED BY THE APPROPRIATION
QUESTION WE HAVE COMPLETED ALL
CONSTRUCTION AT FIVE OF THOSE
TWENTY FIVE IN A SIX ONE WILL BE
COMPLETED WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH.
CONSTRUCTION IS PROGRESSING INTO
REMAINING NINETEEN SITES WITH
THREE ADDITIONAL SITES --
EXPECTED TO BE COMPLETED BY THE
END OF TWENTY NINETEEN AS HAS
BEEN DOCUMENTED THE PROGRAM HAS
EXPERIENCED INCREASED
CONSTRUCTION COSTS FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS -- ALL AVAILABLE
FUNDING -- FROM THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION HAS BEEN FULLY
ALLOCATED TO THESE PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET ACT.
SO BASED UPON OUR PROJECTIONS
AND INITIAL AN ADDITIONAL FORTY
NINE POINT EIGHT FIVE MILLION IS
REQUESTED IN THIS ACTION TO
ADDRESS ANTICIPATED FUNDING
NEEDS IN ORDER TO COMPLETE TESE
PROJECTS -- WITHOUT THE FUNDING
INCREASE -- APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTEEN OF THE REMAINING
PROJECTS TO BE A RISK OF HALTING
CONSTRUCTION OVER THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR -- SOME OF THE
REASONS ARE FOR THE COSTS
INCREASE AT THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED BEFORE I'LL TRY TO BE
VERY BRIEF -- WE HAVE ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS FROM OUR DESIGN
CONSULTANTS -- UNANTICIPATED
SITE CONDITIONS ESPECIALLY IN
OUR RENOVATION PROJECTS WHICH
ARE PART OF THE THE SECOND HALF
OF HICCUP A A LOT OF THE
RENOVATION PROJECT FOR FINDING.
THINGS INSIDE THE WALLS AND
CEILINGS THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
FIXES -- UNFORTUNATELY IN SOME
OF OUR NEW BUILDING PROJECTS WE
HAVE THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
REVISED PRIOR INTERPRETATIONS
REGARDING EXITING FOR THOSE
BUILDINGS WHICH IS LED TO
INCREASE CONSTRUCTION SCOPE IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THOSE
BUILDINGS AND GET OCCUPANCY --
AS I STATED WERE ALSO GETTING
INSPECTIONS OF AREAS IN EXISTING
BUILDINGS WHERE THE FIRE
MARSHAL'S OFFICE REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL -- SMOKE AND AND FIRE --
PROTECTIONS IN THERE THE
ADDITIONAL CAUGHT THE ADDITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ONE DRIVER
COST ANOTHER STRONG DRIVER COST
IS THE INCREASED OVERHEAD
REQUESTS FROM THE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS AS THE PROJECTS GET
DELAYED BY THESE ADDITIONAL
SCOPE OF WORK THAT WAS NOT IN
THEIR ORIGINAL CONTRACTS.
WE'VE TAKEN EFFORTS OVER THE
PAST YEAR TO ADDRESS AND AND
MITIGATE SOME OF THESE
ADDITIONAL OSTS -- WE'VE
IDENTIFIED COMPONENTS OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT ARE LIKELY LEAD TO
INCREASED COSTS AND WILL BE
PURSUING THAT WORK SEPARATELY --
FROM THE EXISTING PROJECTS
THROUGH THE INMATE LABOR PROGRAM.
WE WERE ALSO FOCUSED EFFORTS ON
REMOVING OBSTACLES -- SPECIAL
REGARDING OUR GENERAL
CONTRACTORS -- THESE OBSTACLES
ARE IMPEDING THEIR PROGRESS SO
THAT WE CAN GET THE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS WORK COMPLETED AND
RELEASED HIM FROM THEIR
CONTRACTS -- THE EXTENT OVERHEAD
CLAIMS ARE OUR MAJOR DRIVER
COSTS AND SO THE EFFORT THE
FOCUS WE CAN PUT ON GETTING THE
GENERAL CONTRACTORS TO THE END
LINE -- WILL HELP MINIMIZE ANY
COST INCREASES.
SO.
PRIOR TO QUESTIONS I JUST WANNA
END WITH SAYING THAT HE C<c.cyan></c>
PROGRAM IN THE WE'RE BACK HERE
AGAIN THIS YEAR.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE'RE IN BETTER
SHAPE TODAY THAN WE WERE A YEAR
AGO -- THE OVERALL PERCENTAGE
COMPLETION -- HAS INCREASED FROM
20% TO APPROXIMATELY 70% --
WE'REGONNA NUMBER PRISONS WERE
FULLY COMPLETED WITH THE WORK
AND AND HOPE -- TO KEEP ADDING
TO THAT OVER THE NEXT YEAR -- SO
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST APPROVAL
OF THIS ITEM TO ASSIST US IN
FULL COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM.
SO DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENT BY LA
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES LA -- GO AHEAD.
TOMORROW THE BUDGET OF ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT IN THE
PAST WE HAVE RAISED ISSUES WITH
INADEQUATE INFORMATION IN TERMS
OF THE PROJECT OR THE CIVIC
NEEDS FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE WE
FILL THAT ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT DETAIL.
YOUR BILL DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON IT.
OKAY.
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM [inaudible]
I'M.
I'M GONNA LEAVE THIS ONE OPEN.
TIME PARTLY BECAUSE THIS TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND WHILE IT WOULD
APPEAR THERE'S NOT A CHANGE IN
THE MAY REVISE REGARDING IT.
YOU NEVER KNOW -- BUT BUT AND OF
COURSE WILL ONLY GET TO ANALYZE
THAT AFTER THIS COMMITTEE SENT
JUST RELEASED.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENT IN
THE ITEM AND WILL [inaudible]
MOVE ON OKAY AND BEFORE WE GO TO
OUR NEXT SET OF THINGS.
SO NOW.
WE WILL DO WHAT WE DID -- A FEW
MINUTES AGO ON THE LEGISLATIVE
REQUESTS. FOR THE OF THAT WERE
UNDER THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
AND WHAT WE WILL DO IS.
THERE'S ISSUES -- FIFTEEN
THROUGH.
THIRTY SIX WHERE I WILL READ THE
ITEM AND THEN -- IF THERE'S
SOMEONE HERE.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO IT OR
SOMEONE'S TIME WILL ALLOW THEM?
TO AND THE BUT WE ARE HOLDING
THOSE OPEN [inaudible]
SO.
I'M WE'LL START WITH ISSUE.
FIFTEEN WHICH IS ARE PROPOSING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE COST TO COUNTIES.
OF WHO SEND -- I EVEN KNOWS TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE FROM TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND AND THE DO WE HAVE
ANY PEOPLE HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
RATHER.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SUPPORTER
POST WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE
ISSUE.
FIFTEEN THERE IS PLEASE GET UP
TO THE MY COURT.
I GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DEREK
MORGAN FOR THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- WE FEEL
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE AB.
REINVESTMENT OF OR COUNTIES TO
MAKE AS FAR AS THEIR HEAVY USE
UP TO TODAY PHILLIES.
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS ANTHONY ROBERT
THAT THE JUSTICE COALITION WERE
PRO CO SPONSORS ON SB TWO EIGHT
FOUR AND WE SUPPORT STRONG
SUPPORT THIS THANK.
GOOD MORNING SUPER RALPH FROM
THE PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER
CENTER WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY -- IN
OPPOSITION I WOULD JUST ASK THAT --
YOU KNOW AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
SYSTEMS APPROACH AND THAT IT
DYNAMICS -- AT PLAY REGARDING
THIS ISSUE THAT WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THIS -- PROPOSAL WOULD
MEET THE INTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF KEEPING KIDS CLOSER TO HOME
IS OUR SYSTEM IS ALREADY BEEN
STRUCTURE THAT WAY AND THAT
CERTAINLY AS OUR GOAL -- AND ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
QUINCES OF FUNDING THAT ENHANCES
OTHER PROGRAMS TO BE USED. FOR
THIS PURPOSE LOOK FOR THE FOR
THE CONVERSATION.
THAT IS NOT A NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOU ARE WEARING.
LEAVE THAT ARE ALL OF OUR YOU
BEST OPTION IS TO KEEP THEM
pTHE MASS AND THEM TO MAKE AN
ENTRANCE.
CAN YOU GIVE ME TO COALITION
ALSO AS AS OTHERS HAD IT'S KEY
TO KEEP PEOPLE CLOSE TO HOME.
MOST OF OUR COUNTIES HAVE EMPTY
FACILITIES WITH THE DRAMATIC
DECLINES IN USED CARS RUSSIAN WE
COULD BE A LOT MORE -- A LOT
SMARTER IN A LOT MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY BY YOUNG PEOPLE BACK
TO THEIR COUNTIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA SEVEN TEN
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
THIS PROPOSAL.
COUNTY CERTAINLY SHARE THE BALL
OF HOUSING AS MANY YOUTH AS
POSSIBLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I MEAN IT HAPPENS IN THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CASES I'M MORE
CONCERNED WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS
THAT IT COULD HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE.
OF ACTUALLY TAKING FUNDING AWAY
FROM ACTIVE.
PROGRAMMING INTERVENTION ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
HERE THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
COALITIONS THAT REPRESENTS.
THE FORTY LARGEST COUNTIES AND
AND THIRTY SIX WORLD COUNTIES I
WILL ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF SEE POCKETS HE
SACKED FOR THE SAME REASONS WE
DO BELIEVE THAT DJJ.
IS THE PLACEMENT OF LAST RESORT
WE REALLY TRY TO KEEP OUR KIDS
AND OF INVESTED LATE.
IN A CONTINUUM OF SERVICES
LOCALLY AND AGREE THAT WHERE YOU
WITH AN INCREASE IN THE FEE WE
WOULD SIMPLY BE TAKING MONEY
AWAY FROM PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS WERE.
CAN TO KEEP THOSE KIDS HOME
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENT.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM
SIXTEEN WHICH IS I'M.
WOULD BE A PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THE COUNTY AGE OF JURISDICTION
FROM TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD.
WHICH IS -- WOULD MAKE IT ON
PARALLEL WITH WITH THE STATE DID.
REGARDING DJJ SIX TENSION ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT --
SKEWS ME THIS COMMENT PUBLIC
COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING SU BURRELL PACIFIC
JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER -- THE
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE OF THIS
PROPOSED.
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE IS.
JUST TO ALLOW CERTAIN ADDITIONAL
CATEGORIES OTHER THAN SEVEN OH
SEVEN BE.
YOUTH -- IT WOULD INCLUDE NOW
CERTAIN SEX OFFENSES AND USE
THAT -- ARE AT RISK OF TRANSFER
BECAUSE OF SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
FELONIES AND THERE'S ALSO A A
PIECE OF THIS.
THAT WOULD -- CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE ABOUT WHEN YOU THROUGH
TURN EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE IN
JUVENILE HALL WHEN THEY CAN BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE ADULT JAIL.
LANGUAGE.
THAT IS NOT A NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOU WE ARE OFTEN SPORT.
CAN YOU GIVE ME JUST COLLISION
STRONG SUPPORT AS MEMBERS -- OF
PEOPLE WERE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND SEE THE HARMS
WHEN YOU TAKE YOUNGER PEOPLE IN
A CAR SEAT WITH OLDER PEOPLE.
AND THE ROAD IS IT DO YOU JUST
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
DEREK MORGAN FOR THE L. BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS ON THE SIDE OF RIGHT
IT WILL MOVE TO THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR PERSONS ON PAROLE.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REDIRECT THE
THIRTEEN MILLION THAT'S
CURRENTLY DESIGNATED FOR THE
INTEGRATED SERVICES FOR MENTALLY
ILL PAROLEES. TO A PROGRAM OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR PAROLEES.
I'M TIRED ANY COMMENTS PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE SIDE OF CHRIS
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF C. S. H.
POLICY LINK AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM SEVENTEEN
WHICH LAURIE FORMAN EXISTING
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN FOUND TO
BE INEFFECTIVE -- AND DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING WHICH IS
PROVEN TO WORK FOR THIS
POPULATION -- MAINLY TO REDUCE
AND RECIDIVISM AND A BETTER
RESULTS FOR THE POPULATION.
SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS THIS
BUDGET ASKING SENATOR FOR HIS
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER COMMENT ON THE SIDE OF
MORGAN FOR THE OLYMPIC CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK AS SENATOR BELL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS -- SUPPORT
FOR THIS -- ESPECIALES
POPULATION THANK YOU.
I WOULD NOTE THAT -- LA -- HAS.
IN PREVIOUS REPORTS INDICATED
THAT THE INTEGRATED SERVICES FOR
MENTALLY ILL BURLEY'S PROGRAM
HAD WAS.
HAD NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE.
BEFORE I MOVED TO WELL.
BEFORE I MOVED TO ITEM.
EIGHTEEN BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
SENATOR MORE LUCK HAS SOME.
TIME CONSTRAINTS I WANT TO
RETURN.
TO I AM ZERO TWO FIFTY UNDER THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH ISSUE NINE
FISCAL STAFFING.
AND A PERHAPS BEFORE WE HAVE
PEOPLE COME TO THE TABLE.
I'M IT WAS VOTE ONLY SENATOR
MORE LIKE DID YOU WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT OR DID YOU WANT -- FOLKS
ME MINISTRATION TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
SURE I I I'VE JUST BEEN A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT FISCALE.
OF WILL BE NO FOODS EVERYWHERE
HE SPENT. NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AND I'M
I'M I'M.
I'M JUST WONDERING IS THIS THE
NORMAL ANNUAL COSTS ARE WE
ADDING.
THE SOFTWARE PREPARATION AND
CONSTRUCTION -- WHAT WHAT AM I
GETTING? FOR MY MONEY HERE.
SO PERHAPS WE SHOULD HAVE THE
AFTER THE TABLE [inaudible]
I'M.
AS THIS IS AS WAS POINTED OUT BY
MY COLLEAGUE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE GIFTS THE
AT WE WILL CALL KEEP ON GIVING
WILL CALL KEEPS ON TAKEN AWAY.
PLEASE PROCEED AND I LIKELY IS A
HALF DOZEN PEOPLE TO COME AND
HELP ME OUT.
IN THE A GOOD ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND TO MORE LOCK
THIS IS FUNDING -- SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN
JUDICIAL BRANCH FOR OUR SPECIFIC
IMPLEMENTATION IS THE RESOURCES
NEEDED FOR OUR CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OF THE
PROJECT -- NOT SPEAKING TO
ANYTHING MORE GLOBALLY AS FAR AS
THE BROADER FISCAL
IMPLEMENTATION SO WE'RE HERE TO
BE ABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR SPECIFIC NEEDS.
I'M NOT REALLY ABOUT THE BROAD
IS WHAT CALLING IT
IMPLEMENTATION SO YOU'RE NOT
USING THIS CAL RIGHT NOW WE ARE
THIS YEAR WE BUT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED SOME ISSUES IN TERMS
OF WORKLOAD -- DRIVERS THAT WILL
THAT THIS -- BUDGETARY PROPOSAL
WILL ADDRESS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
ON GOING -- FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL YOU'RE USING TWO SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TRAINS AND I
HAVE DE CASOS WHO COMMIT LITTLE
MAYBE EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE
IN TERMS OF THE SYSTEM
TRANSITION. TO ADDRESS YOUR YES
THANK YOU UNDER COVER OF THE
DIRECTOR OF ACCOUNTING FOR
CARBON FOR THE DIGITAL COUNCIL.
WE IMPLEMENTED DISCO IN JULY.
WE HAVE.
TURN OFF OUR LEGACY SYSTEM IT'S
ONLY FOR HISTORICAL INFORMATION
AT THIS POINT WE ARE USING THIS
GAL IT'S JUST OUR EXPERIENCE IN
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS IS THAT.
JUST BECAUSE A MUCH MORE ROBUST
SYSTEM THEN WE HAD TO USE BEFORE
THERE'S A LOT MORE DATA ENTRY
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK INVOLVED ALL
THE DOCUMENTS COULD SCAN INPUT
INTO THE SYSTEM X. AT AROUND.
AND SO THIS IS A STAFFING THAT
WE FEEL WE NEED TO USE THE
SYSTEM TO ITS FULL FUNCTIONALITY
GOING FORWARD.
ARE THESE LIMITED TERM.
THAT IS A PERMANENT SETTLEMENT
STAFF SO SELFISH CALLOUS NEW BUT
IT'S IT'S GENERATING MORE.
STAFF FOR ITS REQUIRING MORE
WORK ON THE FRONT END TO GET ALL
THE DATA IN THERE SO THAT.
THAT'S FRONT AND SO ON THE BACK
AND WE CAN BE MORE TRANSPARENT
AND HAVE MORE CONTROL OVER THE
ACCOUNTING FUNCTIONS THAT WE
PERFORM.
IN FRONT IT IS NOT IN TERMS OF
YEARS ITS MEANING IN TERMS OF
PROCESSING A PARTICULAR
TRANSACTION THE FRONT END IS
MORE INTENSIVE AND THEREFORE
THERE'S MORE WORK FOR EACH
TRANSACTION.
SO IT'S NOT ONLY VERY EXPENSIVE
SOFTWARE BUT IT'S EXPENSIVE TO
USE.
IT REQUIRES MORE RESOURCES IN
OUR PRIOR SYSTEM THAT THE
TUESDAY.
AND THEN -- IS A WORKING YES
[inaudible]
SATISFACTORILY [inaudible]
YES.
IT IS MUCH MORE ROBUST LOT MORE
INFORMATION YOU CAN ACCESS
DOCUMENTS ONLINE.
OKAY AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
GONNA BE A MUCH BETTER SYSTEM
FOR US [inaudible]
I HOPE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
OF THE ITEM.
CONSCIOUSLY.
YES I DO -- APPRECIATE YOUR NOTE
ABOUT IT BEING PERMANENT
POSITIONS [inaudible]
AND THE CERTAINLY WE HOPE THAT
SUCH A ROBUST SYSTEM MIGHT NOT
CREATE MORE WORK.
BUT THE I WILL ACCEPT THE MOTION
BUT I THINK WILL MAKE A NOTE
WITH STAFF SO THAT WE REVISIT
THIS NEXT YEAR. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IS REALLY NECESSARY TO
HAVE THESE POSITIONS PERMANENT.
AND TO HAVE ANOTHER YEAR OF
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS CALL AND
MAYBE.
IT WILL BECOME EASIER -- RIGHT
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SIDE
OF RIGHT WE HAVEN'T.
YES GO AHEAD.
WHEN THEY ORIGINALLY PROPOSED?
THIS GIRL WAY BACK WHEN THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW WOULD BE.
MORE USEFUL FOR EVEN THE
LEGISLATIVE.
AND WHAT.
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE USE IF WE
WANT TO GET INFORMATION.
WE CAN EASILY GET A YOU KNOW FOR
US PEOPLE THAT LIKE TO LOOK INTO
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
SOME OF US.
SO IN OUR STAFF IN THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES -- I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF THE FULLNESS THAT
I HAD WITH THAT SO I I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE.
WHEN REPORT BACK MAYBE REPORT ON
HOW?
IT CAN BECOME MORE.
TOOL THAT THE LEGISLATORS AND
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
YEARS THANK YOU.
YEAH I JUST READ THE LASTING OF
THE STATE OF BILLION DOLLARS SO
I'D LIKE TO SEE HOW DOES THAT
COMPARE.
TO IMPLEMENTATION OF SIMILAR
SYSTEMS ANOTHER STATE CAPITA.
IN ARE WE IN THERE RIGHT RANGERS.
BE A BY BILL GATES I JUST DON'T
KNOW.
CERTAINLY ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
MOTION [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER -- MORLOCK
[inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE FOR
THE VOTE ONLY ITEM I THINK DID
WE HAVE A VOTE ONLY ITEM THAT --
UNDER MORE BLOCK WAS NOT PRESENT.
FOR OKAY THAT WAS IT OKAY.
WE HAD.
AN ITEM.
HE HAD NOT VOTED ON ALL OF THE
RETURN.
YEAH THERE WAS AN ITEM.
OKAY SO WE'VE WE'VE MOVED -- WE
HAVE VOTED ON THE APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE BOILER PLANT.
AT SAN QUENTIN I WILL RE OPEN
THE ROLE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ON SENATOR MORE LOCKED THIS
WAS APPROVING THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
FOR THE BOILER.
AT SAN QUENTIN.
BUT IT WAS ISSUE -- OKAY WE JUST
HAVE A THEY ARE THERE OKAY.
RIGHT WILL NOW RETURN I THINK
OTHERWISE YOU WOULD VOTED ON
EVERYTHING BUT FOR ME IF I AM
WRONG IF WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
ANYTHING -- RIGHT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO RETURN. TO OUR LATEST.
LEGISLATIVE ITEMS.
IN OUR IT ITEM.
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS.
TO THE AUGMENT THE CURRENT
FUNDING FOR OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OFFERED BY OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
I'M IN OUR STATE PRISON SYSTEM.
ARE THERE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM
.
GO AHEAD.
HI MADAM CHAIR OF THANK YOU US
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE OF SOME
ESCOBAR -- WITH US FOR COUNCIL --
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS --
THIS MEASURE AND I AM SOMEBODY
WHO IS SYSTEM IMPACTED IN ON IT
A LOT OF TIME IN PRISON.
AND THE CBO'S ARE WHAT HELPED ME
DEVELOP EMPATHY AND COMPASSION
AND YOU KNOW MOVING TOWARDS IN
NO SENSE OF EMPATHY AND AND
WORKING TOWARDS.
YOU KNOW THE INSIGHT AND IT WAS
BECAUSE OF WHAT I LEARNED FROM
THE C. BEALS IS WHY I'M STANDING
HERE TODAY.
AND WORKING AS AN EMPLOYEE OF
CENTER FOR COUNSEL AND THE YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO HEAR US AND YOU KNOW AND
YOU WERE TRYING TO INCREASE THIS
BUDGET BECAUSE THIS WORK IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND ALL THE PEOPLE STANDING
BEHIND ME AND I HAVE. FORTY
THREE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE PART OF A COALITION.
AND WE REALLY NEED THIS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS GEORGE LE NOM
REENTRY COORDINATOR FOR THE
GROUP TRAINING INSTITUTE IN
INSIDE OUT.
WE STEM FULL SUPPORT OF THE SO.
ALSO I'M DIRECTIONS ALL FOR THE
GOOD WORK THIS BILL I'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR THE REPAIR IS TO FOR
FIVE YEARS NOW RE ENTERING.
AND YOU CAN OTHER PEOPLE AND AS
WELL WITH MY DEPOSITION I GET --
TO TALKED ALL THE FAMILY SO I
SEE WITH THE GOOD WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING.
THEM REUNIFICATION AND THIS IS
THE BEST ALL.
OF THESE MEN TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO COME BACK AND BE KILLED
PEOPLE TO THE CONTINUE ON HILL
IN OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LEONARD RUBIO I SPENT TWENTY
THREE AND A HALF YEARS AND CDC
ARE.
WHILE INSIDE I'VE.
GOT INVOLVED IN ALL THE PROGRAMS
THAT I COULD.
THESE KIND OF PROGRAMS ARE WHAT
HELPED ME SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITION NINE YEARS AGO.
I'M NOW THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE INSIDE PRISON PROJECT.
RUNNING THE VICTIM OFFENDER
EDUCATION GROUP AND FOURTEEN OF
THE PRESENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SUPPORTER SENATOR
BRADFORD PROPOSAL WE ASK THAT
YOU OFFER THE SUPPORT.
THE INSIDE PRISON PROJECT IS
ALSO PART OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISON WORKGROUP. ONE OF THE
FOUNDING MEMBERS OF THAT
ORGANIZATION.
AND SUPPORT WERE ASKING FOR WILL
HELP.
OUR ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS THE
OTHER EVERYONE MEMBERS OF THE
DPW COALITION. TO BETTER SUPPORT
THE PEOPLE COMING HOME.
AND IN DOING SO THAT HELPS MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER AS WELL.
SO.
WE SUPPORT.
I'M PHILLIP MELENDEZ WITH
RESTORE JUSTICE AND ALSO WORKING
WITH THE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISONED WORK GROUP WHICH IS
AS YOU MENTION -- THIRTY TWO
OTHER MANY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
IN PRISON AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IS BUDGET CHANGE -- IS
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ALSO I AM A BENEFICIARY
OF THESE PROGRAMS -- I TRANSFER
MY LIFE AND ALSO I WOULD MAKE A
POINT.
WHEN FOLKS LIKE DOES COME HOME
WE WE ARE ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
EMPLOYED BY THE SAME
ORGANIZATIONS THESE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHICH YOU
KNOW IS A?
MAKES A BIG DENT IN RECIDIVISM
AND SO -- WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BUDGET CHANGE THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING US
HI MY NAME IS SAM LEWIS ON THE
DIRECTOR OF INSIDE PROGRAMS TO
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION A. R.
C..
WE CREATED ONE OF THE PROGRAM'S
WOULDN'T COME ALIVE FIRST GO
BACK INSIDE AND HELP RUN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
EACH ONE TO LIFE AS THEY GO BACK
INSIDE A TEAM OF NINE NOW
INCLUDE MYSELF.
ALL EXPERIENCE THESE PROGRAMS
WHICH HELPED US.
TRANSFORMERS COME HOME AND GIVE
BACK TO OUR THE DEBATE I'VE BEEN
HOME NOW JUST ABOUT EIGHT YEARS.
AND I CAN SPECIFICALLY SAY THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE THE REASON
WHY I HAVE NOT GONE BACK IN AND
I'M WILLING TO GIVE SO MUCH.
NGUYEN WAS SUPPORT OF THIS --
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HELLO MY NAME IS BETH WACO'S I'M
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INSIGHT GARDEN
PROGRAM WE'RE NOW WORKING IN TEN
ADULT PRISONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ONE JUVENILE FACILITY.
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET AUGMENTATION OF FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE AN
IGP WE KNOW IN PRISON PROGRAMS
RUN BY CBO'S.
BRING PEOPLE OUT OF ISOLATION OF
PRISON IN UNITY SO WE CAN BRIDGE
THE DIVIDE BETWEEN US. TO QUOTE
ONE OF OUR PARTICIPANTS OUTSIDE
HERE IN THE GARDEN.
HELPS US BE PART OF SOMETHING
WITH DIFFERENT RACES
PERSPECTIVES AND MINDSETS WE GET
SKILLS WE NEED FOR CONNECTION.
IT GIVES US A SENSE OF POSITIVE
PURPOSE OF PEOPLE NEED.
THIS IS THE KIND IF THIS IS A
KIND OF RESTITUTION AND GIVING
BACK THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S AMANDA BURGER ON
THE LEADERSHIP ON LEADERSHIP
TEAM OF THE TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPRISONING WORKING GROUP AND
ALSO -- PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITHIN
TAKE GARDEN PROGRAM I WANT TO
OFFER TWO PARAGRAPHS.
FROM A LETTER BY LIEUTENANT
DOUGLAS NAIL WHO WORKED FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
ON THE YARD AT AFTER ALL STATE
PRISON AND HE HAS.
WRITTEN A LETTER IN SUPPORT OF A
SENATOR BRADFORD TO ALLOCATION.
I HAVE WORKED IN STATE PRISONS
FOR NEARLY TWENTY TWO YEARS.
DURING THAT TIME I WITNESSED
FIRST HAND.
THE LONELINESS HOPELESSNESS AND
OPPRESSION YEARS OF CRUSHING
OVERCROWDING WROUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS.
I HAVE WORKED AS A CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER SERGEANT COUNSELOR
LIEUTENANT AND CAPTAIN.
IN EACH OF THESE ROLES I'VE
INTIMATELY EXPERIENCE THE
TRAGEDY.
LIMITED EXPOSURE TO POSITIVE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
BRINGS TO A PRESENT.
PRISONS ARE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
PLACES TO MANAGE WE EXPERIENCE
IN WITNESS THINGS IN PRISON NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO EXPERIENCE.
BUT I'VE ALSO WITNESSED
EXTRAORDINARY ACTS OF KINDNESS
AND HUMANITY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
POSITIVE EXPERIENCES HAVE BEEN
THE DIRECT RESULT OF THE
RESTORATION OF COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMMING IN THE PRISONS.
INCREASING COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT
IN PRISON MANAGEMENT PROGRAMMING
AND REHABILITATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
PRISON ENDEAVOR.
FURTHER WHEN COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
ARE A CONSTANT DAILY PRESENCE ON
PRISON YARDS.
TRANSPARENCY IN OPERATIONS IN
TREATMENT BECOME THE RULE RATHER
THAN THE EXCEPTION.
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE ARNALDO TREVINO
ON THE COUNTLESS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS STANDING WITH HIM WALK
INTO A PRISON THE INSTITUTION
IMMEDIATELY BECOMES A SAFER MORE
EFFECTIVE PLACE?
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN PROGRAMMING
SHOULD BECOME IS COMMON ON
PRISON YARDS AS RAISING WHITE
RAZOR WIRE AND CONCRETE
ESPECIALLY SINCE THEY ARE FAR
MORE EFFECTIVE.
GIVEN THE CHOICE BETWEEN THE
CROWDED HOPELESS DANGEROUS
PRISONS I HAVE EXPERIENCED AND
THE POSITIVE ENCOURAGING
HUMANIZING PLACES I'VE SEEN SOME
OF THEM BECOME.
I WOULD STAND WITH ARNOLD A
THOUSAND TIMES AND WITH THIS
ALLOCATION FOR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU LIEUTENANT DOUGLAS NOW.
MY NAME IS EMILY HARRIS I'M WITH
THE ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND I HAVE BEEN A
VOLUNTEER IN PRISONS FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS -- I THINK THAT
THESE PROGRAMS -- IN A LOT OF
THE MEMBERS WE WORK WITH.
ELLA BAKER CENTER ARE THE MOST
TRANSFORMATIONAL THERE THE
CONNECTIONS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
WHILE THEY'RE BOTH INSIDE AND DO
THE DEEP.
TRANSFORMATIVE WORK BUT ALSO --
IN SUPPORT PEOPLE AS THEIR
RETURNING HOME IN THE COMMUNITY --
AND WHEN LOOKING AT THE LARGER
CDC ARE CORRECTION BUDGET THIS
MONEY IS JUST A FRACTION
ANYTHING THESE ARE ACTUALLY
PROBABLY THE BEST PROGRAMS --
THAT EXIST WITHIN OUR PRESENCE
IN THE STATE.
THE OTHERS YOU CAN CLOSE MY IN
REMOVAL ALONE.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
MY NAME IS MISS A PULLEY THOUGH
I'M WITH THE TRANS LOOKING UP
COALITION -- CHEST ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO WE HELD OUR FIRST
TRANSGENDER PROVIDER FAIR AND I
SEE I AM CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTION MEN.
CALIFORNIANS ADDITION FOR MAN
AND WHAT WE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
THE GIRLS IN TRANS WOMEN THAT
OUR HOUSE IN MEN'S FACILITIES --
IS THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
PROGRAMMING THAT THEY GET IS A
VERY LIMITED AND I FEEL THAT
THIS SPECIFIC ITEM -- WHAT THE
ALLOW FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND THE THE SEED OF
PROGRAMMING THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
CREATED -- SOME HOPING WITH THIS
SPECIFIC ITEM THAT.
IT'S DIVIDED ENOUGH SO WE GET TO
SERVE ALL THE COMMUNITIES THERE
IN INCARCERATED IN PRISON
BECAUSE IT'S TRULY.
VITAL TO FINDING SUPPORT WHILE
INSIDE AND ENSURING THAT YOU
HAVE SUPPORT WHEN YOU'RE COMING
US ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSEPH
CALDERON A LEAD COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER TRANSITIONS CLINIC
NETWORK.
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SUPPORT
THIS -- KNOWING WHILE I WAS
INCARCERATED I'M RETURNING
COMMITTEE MEMBER AFTER STERN
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS HELP GIVE ME THE
SEEDS TO HELP ABILITY.
AND NOW BE A PART OF SERVING MY
COMMUNITY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MIKE A DOCTOR OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ACLU WORKS CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND I HAVE DEEP DEEP RESPECT FOR
THE WORK THAT THEY DO IN PRISONS
ALL OVER THE STATE -- THEY
CREATE SAFE SPACES FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED AS YOU'VE
HEARD A HELP FACILITATE SAFE AND
HEALTHY TRANSITION BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE REALLY
CRITICAL TO BE INNER WORKINGS OF
HE THAT.
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S ANDREW ROVERS IN
STRONG WITH THE JUST COALITION
IS STRONG SUPPORTER CCR GETS
OVER TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
DO A HORRIBLE JOB SO THIS IS TOO
MANY DOLLARS IS MUCH NEEDED AND
I'M.
THINKING.
CAN WE GO FROM THE DISCLOSURE WE
ALSO RELY ON TRANSFORM ADDRESSES
IN OUR CENTER AND MUCH OF THAT
IS LED BY PEOPLE RETURNING HOME
FROM PRISON.
JUST AS ONE QUICK ANECDOTE --
ABOUT A MONTH AGO AFTER NIPSEY
HUSTLES ON MURDER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY
MOST OF THEM FORMERLY
INCARCERATED CAME TOGETHER AND
CALLED FOR A TRUCE IN SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
THAT'S DIRECTLY RELATED TO WHAT
THEY LEARNED IN THESE PROGRAMS
THANK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON THAT ITEM
WAS ITEM.
EIGHTEEN ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO
ITEM NINETEEN WHICH WOULD I I'M.
INCLUDE SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR COUNTY
LIBRARIES AND ON GOING.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SANDY LEVIN
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE WIDE.
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY AND I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY LAW LIBRARY.
MORE THAN A HALF A MILLION TIMES
EACH YEAR.
SOMEONE WALKS INTO ANY LAW
LIBRARY IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THEIR OWN UNIQUE AND OFTEN
DESPERATE STORY.
NEEDING HELP AND UNABLE TO
AFFORD COUNSEL.
AND BY THE WAY THAT FIGURE
DOESN'T INCLUDE PHONE CALLS OR
WEBSITE.
WE WANT TO HELP.
WE TEACH SUPPORT AND GUIDE THEM
AS THEY LEARN TO RESEARCH AN
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES.
IT'S AN ASTONISHINGLY EMPOWERING
AND COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
YEAH.
AND WE KNOW FROM THE BROAD BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT THIRTY TWO
LEGISLATORS WHO ALREADY SIGNED A
LETTER TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR COUNTY
LAW LIBRARY.
OF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO HELP.
THE NEED IS JUST TOO GREAT TO
IGNORE.
WE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE HERE
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ONGOING
FUNDING FOR COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'M JOHN ZORBA'S FROM BUTTE
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY.
TWENTY OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES BY SIZE OF ONE THE
NORTH STATE IS WITHOUT
SUBSTANTIAL.
WORRY RESOURCES THE BAY.
GOING TO PUBLISHER INFORMATION
AND THE DECLINE IN COURT HE ONE
TIME FUNDING WE RECEIVED LAST
YEAR.
YOU AND TO HAMMER AND SHASTA
ALLY.
WE USED BOND TO RESTORE STAFF
THAT HAVE BEEN CUT.
END OF PURCHASE CONSUMER LAW
MATERIALS.
AND JUST IN TIME TO MEET THE
INCREASED NEEDS AIM TO US.
ON ACCOUNT OF PEOPLE DISPLACED
BY THE CAMP FIRE.
WHERE THE GOAL TO PLACE IN THE
NORTHEASTERN CORNER OF THE STATE?
TO HIM HAVE BEEN CLOSED.
BUT IT RE OPENED.
WITH THE ONE TIME FUNDS.
WITHOUT TO NEEDS.
FOR LAW LIBRARY STAFF AND
RESOURCES.
ALL OF THE RURAL NORTH STATE.
WILL BE CUT TO ALMOST
NONEXISTENT.
HI I'M EMILY BURKE FELL DIRECTOR
OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY IN SUPPORT OF STATE
FUNDING FOR COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES.
WITH LAST YEAR'S ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION WE WERE ABLE TO
RESTORE LIBRARY HOURS ARE OPEN
LOCATION PURCHASE MATERIALS FOR
THE PUBLIC ON TOPICS LIKE
HOUSING CHILD SUPPORT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WORKERS RIGHTS IN IMMIGRATION WE
PARTNER WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BAR ASSOCIATION TO HOST A
MONTHLY ALL TOPICS LEGAL CLINIC
AT OUR LOCATION AND COMMUNICATE
WITH NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS.
A SUBSCRIPTION TO LANGUAGE LINE
WE HELP OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR AT OUR
OLD LOCATION AND WOULD LIKE TO
EXPAND SERVICES.
WITHOUT CONTINUED SUPPORT AD
STABLE FUNDING THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THOSE WHO CANNOT
AFFORD AN ATTORNEY BUT COME TO
US EVERY DAY IN CRISIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE FACING SERIOUS.
LIFE CHANGING LEGAL PROBLEMS
POLICE CRITICAL ACCESS TO LEGAL
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE FROM
LIBRARIANS THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM NICHOLAS PILEGGI FROM
THE SONOMA COUNTY LAW LIBRARY --
LET ME START BY THANKING ALL OF
YOU FOR THE ONE TIME FUNDING WE
RECEIVED LAST YEAR AND KEPT US
TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN.
I'M ALSO HERE ON TUESDAY TO
STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING THE FUNDING OF THE
LIBRARIES.
pTHOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS THAT THE
NEED FOR LIBRARIES OPEN THE LAW
LIBRARIES OPEN.
OUR LIBRARY WAS ABOUT TO CLOSE
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE GOT OUR
STAFF AND WE KEPT IT OPEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE KATA
BOOKS AND WE KEPT IT OPEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN RECEIVE
THE STATE FUNDS AND WE SURVIVE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND HERE
WE ARE AGAIN WIPING.
FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT IS
SIMPLE LAST YEAR UNICAL GUYS THE
EXISTENCE OF THE EMERGENCY.
THESE YEAR WE ASK YOU TO GO ONE
STEP FURTHER.
SO WE ARE NOT HERE EVERY YEAR
BEGGING TO STAY OPEN.
IF THE LAW LIBRARY CLOSES I
WOULD FIND ANOTHER JOB.
AND I'M SURE THE LAWYERS WILL
FIND ANOTHER SOURCE FOR THE
MATERIALS.
BUT WHAT ABOUT ALL OUR PATRONS.
THOUSANDS OF CITIZENS OF THE
WALK IN THE LAW LIBRARY EVERYDAY
DESPERATE FOR SOME HELP.
PLEASE FOR THE SAKE KEEP THE
LIBRARIES OPEN THANK YOU.
I'M JAN I'M THE DIRECTOR AND THE
LAST COUNT LAW LIBRARY AND AS I
STAND HERE TODAY ARE.
HELLO.
AND I'M SURE THAT THERE ARE
AGENTS WHO NEED HELP THERE ARE A
BUSINESSMAN.
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
THERE ARE -- TIMERS VICTIMS AND
THEIR CHILDREN WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR YOUR PLAN.
AND THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO HELP.
THAT'S BECAUSE I AM HERE.
UNFORTUNATELY A. B. IS THE
FUNDING THAT WE BOUGHT LAST.
WILL BE OPEN THIS AFTERNOON.
WILL BE OPEN TOMORROW.
WILL BE OPEN THE NEXT.
AND WE'LL BE ABLE.
THE TRUTH IS WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
DO THAT ARE VERY LONG WITHOUT AN
ON GOING APPROPRIATE.
WE REALLY NEED OUT FUNDING THIS
BEARD.
THOSE WHO DOES THE BEST WERE
READY.
IN AN ONGOING OUR SUPPORT FOR AN
ONGOING.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS LARRY MAYER I'M THE
DIRECTOR THE DECEMBER NINETEEN
OH COUNTY LAW LIBRARY.
OUR SITUATION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN MOST THE OTHER
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY OWN ARE REBUILDING.
SO THE STATE FUNDS THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET HAS ALLOWED US TO START
FONG THE COLLECTED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. TO
THEIR PATRONS NOW ARE WILL HAVE
A SAFER AND MORE HABITABLE.
PLACE TO COME FOR ASSISTANCE.
EXTENDED OUR OUTREACH TO THE
RURAL AREAS OF OUR COUNTY.
AND UPDATED OUR RESOURCES FOR
SELF HELP PATRONS IN BOTH PRINT
AND ONLINE RESOURCES.
IN SHORT THE BADLY NEEDED FUNDS
ARE BUILDING.
FROM A DETERIORATING FURTHER AND
RESTART PREVIOUSLY SERVICE IT'S
WE NEED YOUR HELP TO ASSURE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HELP THOSE
WHO NEED US AND ALL PERMANENT
FUNDING SOLUTIONS YES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CAROLINE BROKEN THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
LAW LIBRARY AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR LAST YEAR'S FUNDING -- WITH
LAST YEAR'S MONEY WE WERE ABLE
TO RESTORE SATURDAY AN EVENING
HOURS SO THAT PEOPLE THAT CAN'T
AFFORD.
OF THEIR OWN.
LEGAL MATERIALS AND HAVE ACCESS
TO IT WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE
TIME OFF OF WORK.
UP WITH THOSE EXTRA HOURS WE'VE
ALSO CREATED NEW PROGRAMMING
INCLUDING A COMMUNITY LAW NIGHT.
AND A RECORD EXPUNGEMENT CLINIC
ALLOW PEOPLE.
TO RECORDS TO GET BACK REPORTS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU AGAIN ANNE.
NAME IS BRENDA SCHULTZ SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY LAW LIBRARY AND I
SUPPORT THIS MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS ON
THE SIDE OF ALL RIGHT SO THE
NEXT ITEM.
IS A REQUEST FOR INCREASING FOR
FINDING. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION AND
PREVENTION THE CALVET PROGRAM.
THEY ASK IS THIRTY NINE MILLION
PER YEAR FOR THREE YEARS
[inaudible]
AND THERE'S IN A SEPARATE ASK.
FOR GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
BUT THAT WOULD SET ASIDE 15% OF
THE GRANT FUNDING FOR RURAL
CITIES.
I'M HAVING A POPULATION OF FORTY
THOUSAND OR LESS.
SO -- IF THERE'S ANY SPEAKERS ON
THIS ITEM YOU CAN COME TO THE
MIKE.
I AM IT'S TWO PARTS BUT YOU CAN
SPEAK TO WHICHEVER PARTY LIKE.
BUT IS BRED SILVER SAN MATTEO
ARM REPRESENT MOM SPENT ACTION
I'M ARM SUPPORTING BE --
INCREASED BUDGET TO THIRTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO ON THE
PROGRAMS IN IN THE AREAS OF
STATE THAT NEED THEM THE MOST.
LEVY URBAN AREAS.
SO IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME'S CHRISTINE
NYGAARD I'M FROM OAKLAND AND
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE IN AMERICA.
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIRTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS CALVET.
I PARTICULARLY FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HIT HARDEST
BY COMPILING.
HELLO MY NAME IS ARE YOU FILING
COMMIT DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE -- BRIEFLY
SAID -- CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
LEADER ON THE IN THE FIGHT FOR
GUN SAFETY.
IN OUR GUN LAWS TRUNKS IN THE
NATION PUBLICLY.
NOT IN OUR BUDGET.
WE'RE SPENDING MUCH MUCH LESS
NECESSITY OF CHEAP BIGGEST
REDUCTIONS AND CAN BOUNCE RECENT
YEARS MASSACHUSETTS AND NEW YORK
AND SPENDING FORTY TWENTY TIMES
AS MUCH PER CAPITA AN ANALOGOUS
PROGRAMS.
CALVET THAT'S A BIG PART OF WHY.
DON'T PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE HALF
AS LIKELY BE SHOT TO DEATH IN
THOSE STATES THAT THE STATE.
YOUR COOKING VIOLENCE IT'LL
SHOOTINGS 40% SEVEN YEARS AFTER
ITS SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
FUNDING.
THE GOVERNOR THIS MORNING
PROPOSED A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
AFTER CALVET -- NOT THIS BILL
REQUEST FOR THIRTY NINE MILLION
THREE YEARS OF THESE PROGRAMS --
CAN HAVE THE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
TO ACTUALLY GET OFF THE GROUND
AND REPLICATE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS IN MORE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THESE
RESOURCES.
ALSO URGE YOU TO LOOK UP FULLY
FUNDS CALVET PROGRAM BUT IF THE
BARE MINIMUM THAT THE OTHER
STATES HAVE RECEIVED A PROVIDED
PROVIDES PREVENTION THEIR
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
THAT'S HI MY NAME IS CAROL
ROGERS.
I AM FROM ELK GROVE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALVET PROGRAM
FUNDING TO THIRTY NINE MILLION.
I AM -- LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
BEING SPENT IN THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL
INCREASE IT THANKFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING IN TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION.
LOOK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
TO BUT IN THE FULL THIRTY NINE
MILLION THANK YOU.
I AM CHRIS A LOCALIZED AREA I
LIVE IN ALAMEDA [inaudible]
AND BY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THOSE OF YOU WANT TO SPEAK
INCOME UP CLOSE TO THE MIKE SO.
I MERRY LEMURS ADDO I AM FROM
DAVIS CALIFORNIA I'M I'M WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION.
AND I AM I'M.
IN FAVOR OF THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS CALVET.
AND ALSO FOR IT GOING TO THE
MOST -- IN NEED VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
MY NAME IS CASSANDRA WHAT STONE
I'M ALL SOME AND I ALSO SUPPORT
THE INCREASE CALVET FUNDING TO
THIRTY NINE MILLION.
FUNDS GOING TO THE HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME IS TERRY TO WHERE I'M
FROM DAVIS AND WOODLAND.
AND I SUPPORT THIRTY NINE
MILLION GOING TO HELP THEM
ASHLEY -- TO ARTISTIC AREAS
THANK.
HI I'M SUZIE MICKEY WALNUT CREEK
I ALSO SUPPORT THE THIRTY NINE
MILLION OR CALVET VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION --
BUT THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE MONEY GOING
TO COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT MOST
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ON SPEAKERS
ON THIS ITEM.
I'M I WOULD NOTE THAT -- B. M..
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE BASICALLY DID
INCREASE -- CALVET OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND IT WAS RESHAPED.
I'M.
JUST SOME OF OUR WORK. TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WAS FINDING
[inaudible]
I'M. SIX PROGRAMS EDWARD HAD
DEMONSTRATED THEIR SUCCESS IN
GUN VIOLENCE REDUCTION.
AND AS A RESULT THERE WAS
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITIES
FOR EXAMPLE TO IN MY DISTRICT
RICHMOND IN OAKLAND.
AND BOTH COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED AND THEY'VE RECEIVED
FUNDING OVER A COUPLE OF YEARS.
BUT MORE THAN COUPLE BUT HAVE
EXPERIENCED A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION.
IN GUN VIOLENCE NOW IT'S LIKE
ANYTHING -- IS IT DIRECTLY DUE
TO THE CALVET.
FINDING NOT ALONE BUT CERTAINLY
THE CALVET FINDING -- ASSISTED
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHEN BECAUSE
THEY MADE A PRIORITY. TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENTED PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AND THERE IT
IS THERE'S RESULTS.
SO THE I APPRECIATE THE PUBLIC
HAVE SHOWN UP IN.
DISCUSS THIS ITEM IS THERE ANY
OTHER.
COMMENT ON THE ITEM GO AHEAD
SENATOR BILL.
YESTERDAY OF I CHAIRED THE
MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE HAD A
PRESENTATION ON NOV SUICIDES.
AND WE GOT THE NUMBER THE LATEST
NUMBERS IN CALIFORNIA'S.
FORTY TWO HUNDRED DOES SLASH
YOUR TO THE SUICIDE.
NUMBER ONE CAUSES GUNS.
THE SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY DO
THE GUNS AND THERE WERE. FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND ATTEMPTED SUICIDES
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SO -- THIS IS A MAJOR PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS I AGREE.
IN THIS COMMITTEE VOTERS OF
SEXUALLY OF ALSO A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES I I DON'T KNOW IF THE IF
THIS PARTICULAR ASK INCLUDES IT
BUT I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD ALSO LOOK AT MAKING SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE.
TRAININGS REGARDING THE EXISTING
LAW WE HAVE THE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER.
WHICH COULD BE USED BY.
MANY FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES TO
HELP PREVENT SUICIDE.
ESPECIALLY BY GUN -- WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
WHICH IS ITEM TWENTY ONE AND
THAT IS.
TO INCREASE FUNDING. FOR THE
TESTING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE -- AND THOSE ARE
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS RAPE
KITS NOT BY ME -- IT IS THE
CASTING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE THAT IS PAINSTAKINGLY
ARE GATHERED FROM A VICTIM.
AT A HOSPITAL.
AND THE FUNDING REQUEST IS FOR
SOME GENERAL FUND -- ALLOCATION
TO DO JAY AND ALSO FOR THE DOJ'S
LAB AND THEN A ONE TIME TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION
FOR THOSE.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT HAVE THEIR OWN LABS DO NOT
USE DOJ.
M. ANY SPEAKERS ON THIS ITEM.
HI ANNA CAL E. R. WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY' OFFICE I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST AND
SENATE BILL.
TWENTY TWO I DO DA O'MALLEY
BELIEVES IT'S IMPERATIVE THESE
KIDS ARE TESTED IN A TIMELY
MANNER MANNER AND NOT WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
RIGHT ANY OTHER SPEAKERS ON THE
OUTSIDE OF OKAY WE'LL GO TO ITEM
TWENTY TWO WHICH IS.
A ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF THREE
MILLION.
OR REENTRY PREPARATION AND
SERVICES FOR TRANS GENDER GENDER
NON CONFORMING IN INTERSEX
PEOPLE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SANTA ROSA DO YOU JUST COALITION
IS STRONG SUPPORTER OF EVERYBODY
DESERVES ENTRY PROGRAM IN ON AND
ALL THAT AND ALSO -- AFTER
LEAVES ANOTHER HEARING BY
SUPPORT THE NEXT ITEM TO NUMBER.
TWENTY THREE OKAY THAT'S RIGHT
IF IT IF THERE ARE ANY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO LEAVING OR
COMMENTING ON BOTH THIS AND THE
CDC OUR PROGRAMMING ACCESSING
CREDITS YOU MAY DO IT.
NOW.
RIGHT I MY NAME'S MISSIVE PULIDO
AGAIN I'M I'M THE POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE TRANSIT THE
NO COALITION.
OR ONE OF THE ONLY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT DOING ADVOCACY WORK BUT
ALSO PROVIDING DIRECT SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THE TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS ONLY ABOUT A HANDFUL AND SO
WE WE ARE BASED IN LOS ANGELES
AND CONTACTS -- WHERE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT SUBMITTED THE
SPECIFIC BUDGET ASK BUT IT WAS A
PART OF A LARGER ASK THAT WOULD
HAVE CREATED?
I'M A PIECE OF THE GENERAL FUND
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
TRANSGENDER ONENESS IN EQUITY
FUND THAT WOULD HAVE DONE THINGS
SUCH AS LOCAL DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS.
IT WOULD HAVE ON FOCUSED ON
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROVIDERS.
AND IT WOULD HAVE FOCUSED ON A
LAND PROJECT THAT WOULD HAVE
INCLUDED -- YES RANCHING
PROGRAMMING CARE BUT WE GOT.
ASK LIKE THIS -- AND SO THIS
SPECIFIC OSLO CASES ON REENTRY
PROGRAMMING FOR TRANS PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF PRISON -- A LOT OF
THE TIME WHAT WE SEE AMONG OUR
FOLKS IS THAT THERE ARE NO
SPECIFIC FACILITIES.
THAT ARE SAFELY ON THERE ARE
SAFE FOR TRANS PEOPLE ONCE
THEY'RE RELEASED SO ONCE PEOPLE
COME OUT AND TRY CENTER.
THE MAIN THING THAT THEY NEED IS
HOUSING AND WE BARELY HAVE
PLACES TO REFER THEM TO BECAUSE
A LOT OF THE TIME.
I'M TRANSITIONAL LIVING PROGRAMS
EMERGENCY HOUSING OPTIONS ARE
ALL SEX SEGREGATED OR GENDER
SEGREGATED -- AND SO WHEN TRANS
AMAN ARE FORCED TO BE IN MEN'S
FACILITIES THEY FACED BY LANDS
AND WHEN TRANSAMERICA SO WOMEN'S
FACILITIES.
THEY ALSO FACED BY LANDS AND SO
THIS SPECIFIC US REALLY FOCUSES
ON CREATING TRANSPACIFIC
PREENCHER PROGRAMMING THAT
ADDRESSES THE SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
ALSO LOOKING THINGS THAT LIKE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
I REALLY PROVIDING SUPPORT TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET.
I'M AND LIKE I MENTIONED THIS IS
A PART OF A LARGER ASK -- THE
WILLIAMS IS TO ESTIMATED THAT
THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND CONSTABLE LIVING IN --
CALIFORNIA IN GENERAL AND SO.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT POPULATION
THAT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED HERE
IN THE CAPITAL -- AND NOT AT ALL
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND SO
WE HOPE THAT THIS IS JUST THE
STARTING POINT OF A LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN.
PRIORITIZE OUR COMMUNITY -- AND
SO I WOULD REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE -- STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE SPECIFIC AGENDA ITEM
[inaudible]
X..
GOOD MORNING THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS ALLOCATION AND WE HAVE
WORKED WITH MANY INCARCERATED
INFORMALLY FRUSTRATED TRANS
GENDER [inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS AND EVEN BEING BASED
IN OAKLAND IN THE BAY AREA WE
HAVE TO STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE AND IDENTIFYING PLACES
THAT THEY CAN GO UPON RELEASE.
I'M AND FOLKS BASIS SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF VIOLENCE WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED AND THEN COMING
HOME OFTEN PEOPLE ARE.
I'M BASING IT EVEN MORE ISSUES
AND CONCERNS AROUND THEIR
TRANSITION HOME AND SO BEING
ABLE TO HAVE.
SERVICES THAT ARE FOR TRANS
FOLKS SPECIFICALLY -- WILL BE
ACTS WILL YOU HUGE SUPPORT AND
PEOPLES -- PREVENTING RECIDIVISM
RATES AND BEING ABLE.
TO HOUSE.
GIVE ME DOESN'T COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT WE ALSO URGE YOU TO HAVE
SEPARATE HEARINGS ON THE MERGING
OF THE ARTS WITHIN C. C. R..
WHICH IS ALSO CONTRIBUTING
INCREDIBLY TO THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION SAFETY
INSIDE AND ABILITY TRANSITION
HOME.
IN A GOOD WAY.
HI I'M ANNA CENTER WITH
TRANSITIONS CLINIC NETWORK I RUN
A MEDICAL DISCHARGE CLINIC
INSIDE ST CLINTON AND DO YOU SEE
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS PER
RELEASE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN AROUND LACK OF SERVICES
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY SO.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
ALL RIGHT SEE NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT ITEM WILL GO TO
ITEM TWENTY THREE THE CDC OUR
PROGRAMMING ACCESSING CREDIT.
I'M THIS IS.
NOT A DOLLAR.
AMOUNT IT IS A ASKING THAT THE
SAME CREDIT EARNING AND SENATE
JUST BE PROVIDED -- FOR FOLKS IN
THE CDC OURS FIRE CAMPS AS IN
THE STATE PRISONS.
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND BURNING AT EMILY HARRIS MEL
BAKER CENTER WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH SENATOR WIENER ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND ALSO WITH A
GROUP OF MEN WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AT SYNC BUTTON ON
MANY OF WHO.
ARE TOO OLD TO PARTICIPATE AND
OUR AMPS BUT WERE ORIGINALLY
CONVICTED OF VIOLENT FELONIES.
AND THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
THEIR STATUS REEVALUATED.
GO TO FIRE CAMP AND HAVE
INCREASED CREDIT EARNING ACCESS --
BUT MANY OF THEM ARE TWO ELDERLY
OR ARE INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING IN OUR CAMP BUT
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
SAME LEVEL OF RECOGNITION FOR
THE KINDS OF POSITIVE
PROGRAMMING.
AND THINGS THAT THEY'RE DOING --
IN THE STATE ISN'T THATIS AFTER
IT WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVING MEASURE.
ACTUALLY HELP CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS
A RESOURCES NEEDED FOR A LOT OF
THE ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE ASKED.
AFTERNOON MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ITEM -- AND IN PARTICULAR
PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS TO
CREDIT EARNING -- AS EMILY
MENTIONED THERE IS CURRENTLY A
DISPARITY -- BASED ON SOMEBODY'S --
ABILITY TO SERVE EMPIRE CAM
SOMEBODY'S AGE -- AND THERE
SHOULD BE GREATER PARITY -- AND
GREATER CREDIT EARNING REALLY
ACROSS THE BOARD I'M ONE OF THE
OTHER BENEFITS OF CREDIT EARNING
IS THAT IT.
PROVIDES A REAL INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROGRAMMING AND AS WE KNOW.
PROGRAMMING ON BOTH IS A MEASURE
THAT -- HELPS REDUCE RECIDIVISM
RATE SAFER SPACES WITHIN.
I'M AND HELP BRING DIGNITY TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
TO FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
THINK THIS IS A WONDERFUL IDEA.
HI I'M ANNA STEINER FROM
TRANSITIONS CLINIC NETWORK JUST
ONE TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS AS LAKE ISN'T THAT GARDEN
PROGRAM -- IN TECH PARDON IS IN
FULL SUPPORT OF BETTER EARNINGS
GOOD BEHAVIOR AND READ.
A RANS ATLANTIC BUT LISTEN WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR THE HEALTH
TRANSITIONS -- HOW PILOT IN ITS
FOR FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
OVER FIVE YEARS?
US LET'S NOT FIVE MILLION EACH
YEAR IT'S FIVE MILLION OVER FIVE
YEARS FOR THIS.
I'LL TRANSITIONS HUB
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT ANY NCDC
ARW.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
HELLO GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
SURE SHOULD BE IT I'M A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE TRANSITIONS CLINIC
NETWORK.
TRANSITIONS CLINIC NETWORK IS A
NETWORK OF SEVENTEEN HEALTH
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. TO CHRONICALLY
ILL INDIVIDUALS RETURNING FROM
OUR STATE PRISON SYSTEMS ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS -- TRAIN AND HIRE
INDIVIDUALS WITH HISTORIES OF
INCARCERATION.
OY THEM IN THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING.
SO I AM HERE -- REPRESENTING OUR
MANY PARTNERS INCLUDING THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
ASSOCIATION AMONG OF OUR OTHER
SYSTEMS AS I MENTIONED.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AT THE RISK OF SOUNDING A LITTLE
BIT OVER DRAMATIC IT IS AN ISSUE
OF LIFE AND DEATH.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT PEOPLE
LEAVING PRISON IS THERE TWELVE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
COMMUNITY?
AND FOUR OUT OF FIVE OF THESE
REASONS ARE HEALTH RELATED
REASON.
DRUG OVERDOSE CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE.
SUICIDE AND CANCER SO THERE'S A
REAL IMPERATIVE TO PROVIDE CARE
TO THESE INDIVIDUALS COMING HOME.
I'M AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE WE
SPEND TWO BILLION DOLLARS ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
INSIDER STATE PRISON SYSTEMS.
AND ZERO THESE DOLLARS ARE TO
PROVIDE.
CARE COORDINATION FOR PEOPLE
WITH COMPLEX CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS RETURNING TO THE
AMBULATORY CARE SYSTEM.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS A PROVIDER
THAT SEES THESE PATIENTS AND
JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXAMPLES
REALLY QUICKLY.
SOMEONE WHO'S AS FOR CALLING
ANSWER GETTING CHEMOTHERAPY
RELEASED WITH NO CONTINUITY OF
CARE.
I'M AND I SEE THEM MANY MONTHS
LATER AND THEY STILL DON'T HAVE
CONNECTION TO CARE RISKING THEIR
LIVES.
MANY MONTHS HAVE GONE BY WHERE
THEY HAVE NOT GOTTEN CARE
ANOTHER EXAMPLE SOMEBODY WHO HAS
SEVERE EMPHYSEMA RELEASE WITH A
SMALL TANK OF OXYGEN.
THAT RUNS OUT -- AFTER THE BUS
RIDE HOME TO THEIR COMMUNITY
WITH NO SET UP FOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
THIS PILOT WAS DESIGNED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR MEDICAL
COLLEAGUES AT CDC ARE -- IT'S A
PILOT TO PROVIDE SERVICES CARE
CONTINUITY OF CARE WHICH IS
REALLY THE STANDARD OF CARE IN
THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN PEOPLE LEAVE HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS ARE PROVIDED CONTINUITY
OF CARE TO LINK THEM TO SERVICES
IN THE COMMUNITY?
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL -- IS
REALLY AIMED AT THE HIGHEST RISK
PEOPLE THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE --
OVER THIS PERIOD OF TIME AND
WHILE ITS PILOT -- IT'S ACTUALLY
NOT A PILOT IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS WHERE WE
CONNECT PEOPLE FROM THE JAIL TO
THE HEALTH SYSTEM.
IN SHOWN TO REDUCE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT UTILIZATION
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND PREVENT
FUTURE CONTACT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO.
I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PILOT -- AND TO BRING OF THE
WORK IN.
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING IN OF THE
ALL THE INVESTMENTS IN
HEALTHCARE IN THE SYSTEM -- TO
THE COMMUNITY STANDARDS THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH CALDERON
TRANSITIONS CLINIC.
WORK AND I PROMISE TO BE REALLY
BRIEF -- PRIOR TO INCARCERATION --
MY ONLY CONTACT WITH MEDICAL WAS
FOR MANDATORY SHOT.
LOVED ONES DYING HAVE BEEN SHOT --
MY FATHER DIED DISTRO MY MY MY
MY GRANDFATHER DIED DISTRO IS MY
FATHER DIED OF A MASSIVE HEART
ATTACK MY UNCLE AND GRANDFATHER
DIED OF STROKE -- WHEN I WAS
RELEASED FROM PRISON THE AGE OF
TWENTY NINE A WASN'T RELEASED AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY NINE I WAS
DIAGNOSED HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE?
MY BIGGEST CONCERN WITH ON
RELEASE WAS GETTING REFILLS AND
THAT'S HOW I WAS INTRODUCED TO
TRANSITION.
NETWORK I WAS ALMOST OUT OF
MEDICATION RAN ACROSS ACROSS THE
TRANSITION NETWORK MANY HEALTH
WORKER.
REALLY CHANGED MY LIFE BECAUSE
IT CAN ONLY BRING ME INTO
PRIMARY CARE AND TEACH ME HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE MEDICAL FIELD.
THEY ALSO LINK BE WITH ALSO ALL
MY SOCIAL NEEDS THAT I NEED.
AND ON THAT NOTE SEEING THE NEED.
AND SEEING THE HELP AND REACHING
BACK AND HELPING MY OWN
COMMUNITY.
NOW COMMUNITY HEALTH.
AND JUST.
YOU KNOW -- I CAN'T REINSTATE
WITH WHAT DOCTOR SHOULD BE SAID
WE IT IS A LIFE AND DEATH MATTER.
AND I KNOW IT SAVED MY LIFE AND
GAVE ME A CAREER THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR DAVID
TANISHA HEALTH POLICY CONSULTANT.
MY CONSULTING FIRM RECEIVED --
CONTRACT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
REENTRY PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF PRISON AND JAIL
AND HOW DO YOU GET THEM INTO
HEALTH AND AND THAT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROGRAM. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE FOUND THAT WAS
THE MOST SURPRISING TO US WAS
THAT THERE REALLY IS NO.
INSERTED ORGANIZED EFFORT
ORDINATED EFFORT TO MOVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MEDICALLY FRAGILE OR
COMING OUT OF STATE PRISON.
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
SO THE THE PROPOSAL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY I THINK.
IS THAT IT'S A SMALL THING THAT
CAN BE DONE THAT MAKE WILL HAVE
A HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S LIVES
SO WE THANK YOU.
MY HAS A VALIDATOR CENTER WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THIS PILOT PROGRAM -- WE'VE
BEEN A PARTNER WITH TRANSITION
TO ENACT.
AND HAVING DONE ADVOCACY AT THE
STATE LEVEL AROUND PASSIONATE
RELEASE AN ELDERLY ROLE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT MEDICALLY FRAGILE
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR TRANSITION
HOME -- AND FOUND THAT.
HOPING THAT THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS CAN HELP US BRING MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE -- AGING AN
ELDERLY MENTOR MEDICALLY FRAGILE
ON FROM OUR PRESENT
MADAM CHAIR.
AND REBEL CHRISTY BUT I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL.
OUR CLINICS SEE MANY OF THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
IN OUR CLINICS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT COUNTIES HAVE PROGRAMS
SIMILAR TO THIS FOR THEIR JAIL
POPULATIONS IN THE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED.
CERTAINLY BENEFIT FROM A SUMMER
PROGRAM [inaudible]
OUR STATE.
WE'LL NOW GO TO ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PILOT IT'S REQUESTING A
THREE MILLION ONE TIME
ALLOCATION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PILOT A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
HELLO AGAIN MADAM PERSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MELENDEZ WITH RESTORE JUSTICE WE
ARE SPONSORS WITH THE BILL WITH
A GLAZER AND WE SUPPORT THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE BY THE
PROGRAM.
WE BELIEVE THAT PUTTING
SURVIVORS OF CRIME AT THE
FOREFRONT AND HAVE BEEN FUNDS
WILL PARTY SPACE THEM.
IS A REALLY KEY COMPONENT TO
TRANSFORMATION AND
REHABILITATION.
AND I AM MYSELF.
WOOD HAD A ONE OF THE MOST
PIVOTAL MOMENTS IN MY LIFE AS
FAR AS MY TRANSFORMATION GOES.
HAVING TO FACE SURVIVORS OF
PRIME.
IT IS LOOKING AT HARM IT'S
REALLY -- ACKNOWLEDGING IT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT UP.
AND AND THE BUDGET THAT COMES
WITH IT THANKS.
RUBIO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSIGHT PRISON PROJECT WE ARE
AMPLE SUPPORT OF ANY KIND OF
PROGRAMMING THAT.
PROMOTES RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS
WE HAVE FOUND THAT IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO BRING HIM.
CALDERON TRANSITIONS THANK
NETWORK WOULD LIKE ALSO.
IT WILL SUPPORT.
ORGAN FOR THE ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS ARE WE ON
STRONG SUPPORTER SENATOR GLAZERS
BILL AND AT THAT ARE OPENED UP
CITIES WERE ALSO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO INVEST HEAVILY
IN [inaudible]
DEALER.
I AMANDA BURGER INTAKE ARDEN
PROGRAM IN.
TRANSFORMING OF IMPRISONED
WORKING GROUP WAS VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND BELIEVE THAT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS THE WAY
TO BRING HEALING TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
ANY OTHER A PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT WILL MOVE TO NUMBER TWENTY
SIX WHICH IS -- A AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATION OF THIRTY SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION TO SPORT
TWENTY FIVE NEW JUDGES
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- MIKE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ELIZABETH THAT'S BEEN US
ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THAT
HOLDS THE DISTINCTION OF HAVING
THE BIGGEST GAP BETWEEN THE
JUDGESHIPS THAT ARE AUTHORIZED
IN THE JUDGESHIPS THAT -- HAVE
BEEN DEMONSTRATED THROUGH THE
JUDICIAL NEEDS PROJECT VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPENDING.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS PROUD CORD
FUNDING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD MAKE
AN ONGOING AUGMENTATION OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN DISCRETIONARY FUNDS. FOR
ALL TWELVE COURTS.
A PLUS FORTY FIVE MILLION
ADDITIONAL FOR THE MOST UNDER
FUNDED COURTS [inaudible]
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WERE IN
FULL SUPPORT.
OF THIS AUGMENTATION IT'LL HELP
US RESTORE CUTS TO THE COURTS --
THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED OF THE
LAST TEN OR TWELVE YEARS AND
ALSO INCREASE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AND WHEN.
YOU.
WE SHALL CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
ALSO SUPPORT THIS MONEY WILL
HELP COURTS TO CONTINUE THE
MOMENTUM.
MADE LAST YEAR BY REINVESTING
SERVICES LENGTHENING COURT HOURS
AREN'T STAFF.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS ON THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHTS WILL GO -- TO ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT IT'S A REQUEST FOR
ONE TIME APPROPRIATION OF TEN
MILLIONFOR GENERAL FUND OR LA
COUNTY'S REFURBISHMENT OF THE
CHALLENGER MEMORIAL YOU CENTER
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M ADAM BETTINO DIRECTOR WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PROBATION.
UNFORTUNATELY -- CHIEF MCDONALD.
CAN BE HERE TODAY I'M SURE
AGGRESSIVE SHE CAN BE HERE.
SHE WANTS TO SHARE HER PROFOUND
APPRECIATION FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BUDGET
OZELL.
I'M GONNA READ A BRIEF STATEMENT.
BUT WE HAVE MUCH WORK LEFT TO DO
WE ARE PROUD TO REPORT THAT
TODAY WE HAVE ONLY 25% OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN DETENTION.
WE HAD A DECADE AGO.
AS A RESULT WE HAVE THE
COMMISSION AMPS THAT CAN BE
TRANSPORT.
OUR GOAL IS TO REMOVE THE
BARRIERS THAT ARE YOUNG ADULTS
SPACES THEY TRY TO NAVIGATE
BINDING LIVING WAGE JOBS.
BY CREATING A SAFE AND HELP
BUILD SPACE FOR CITIZENS. TO
CREATE CRITICAL JOB TRAINING AND
LIFE SKILLS SUPPORT.
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO SLEEP.
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL WILL COME
FROM OR HOW THEY WILL PAVE THEIR
BOOKS?
IF WE CAN DE COMMISSIONING
CONVERT THIS FACILITY WE CAN
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES A
REAL JOB TRAINING.
NEXT STUDENTS TO LIVING WAGE
JOBS AND ADDRESSES TRAUMA.
THIS WILL HELP CHANGE A LIFE
TRAJECTORY OF YOUNG ADULTS.
AND ULTIMATELY GENERATIONS OF
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
HELPING LA COUNTY CREATE A SPACE.
TO ALLOW YOUNG ADULT TO GROWING
HE'LL.
A PLACE WHERE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOCUS ON
PROVIDING SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED.
AND NEGLECTED MEMBERS OF OUR
OMMUNITY AND ENABLING THEM TO
STRIVE.
IT IS A POWERFUL STATEMENT BY
THE STATE THE COUNTY AND THE
COMMUNITY.
WE INTEND TO FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE APPROACH OF THE LAST
THREE DECADES.
BY DISMANTLING WHAT IS LIKELY
THE LARGEST JUVENILE DETENTION
CENTER IN THE NATION. TO CREATE
A TOTALLY RENOVATED CENTER.
FOCUSED ON THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES IN A RESIDENTIAL
SETTING.
WE BELIEVE THE TIME HAS COME FOR
THIS CHANGE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR STATE
PARTNERS.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS READY
WILLING AND ABLE TO TAKE THIS
STEP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
ON A SIDE TRIP PRESENT IN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR PUTTING THIS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEES APPROVAL OF OUR
BUDGET REQUESTS INTO FUTURE
HEARING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ
WITH THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA HERE AND
AND PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS SITE
I THINK THIS PROPOSAL REALLY.
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH.
TO REPURPOSE IN OUR COUNTY
FACILITIES TO REALLY MOVE THEM
IN A MORE THERAPEUTIC UPDATED
MODEL TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING THE BEST
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND NEEDS TO
MEET.
THOSE OF THE COMMUNITY AND SO WE
WOULD CERTAINLY -- URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS AND WELCOME
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
BEST TO ENHANCE THE TYPES OF
OPPORTUNITIES.
RIGHT ANY OTHER SPEAKERS ON THAT
ITEM.
RIGHT WILL MOVE NOW 229- I DON'T.
WHICH WOULD BE A REIMBURSEMENT
TO THE COUNTY FOR THE GOLDEN
STATE KILLER TRIAL COSTS.
HI TECH IN HERE BEHALF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE WANT TO
REGISTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST TO
ALLOW THE COUNTIES IMPACTED.
I'M BY THE TRIAL OF THE GOLDEN
STATE KILLER TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT DESPITE THE
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS -- WE
BELIEVE THIS CASE IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN SIGNIFICANT IN
NATURE THERE WAS THIRTEEN
MURDERS OVER THE RATES AND OVER
A HUNDRED BURGLARIES AND
ROBBERIES.
AND THE CASE ALSO SPANS FORTY
YEARS AND INVOLVES CONDUCT IN
MULTIPLE NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY.
THAT COMPRISE NEARLY A THIRD OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION SO WE
SUPPORT.
BUDGET REQUEST TO ALLOW THE
COUNTIES TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TRIAL FOR THE DEFENSE AND THE
PROSECUTION THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH HAS BEEN -- SOME
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA A COALITION OF
FOURTEEN OF THE LARGEST COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA MANY OF WHOM WERE
JURISDICTIONS AFFECTED BY THE
DECADE LONG CRIME SPREE OF THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AT ELEVEN TEN THE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STOCK SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS ON THIS ITEM.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO ITEM THIRTY
THE CLERMONT POLICE STATION
[inaudible] TWO MILLION. FOR
ONE TIME RETROFITTING AN
OCCUPANT IMPROVEMENTS ARE CLEAR
MY POLICE STATION ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY WILL GO TO THIRTY ONE IT'S
SO ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF MONEY.
FOR CITIES A BALDWIN PARK AS
USER WEST COVINA AND SELF THE
MONEY -- DEAD BODY WORN CAMERAS
AND OTHER TECHNOLOGIES.
ANY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT -- SKEWS
ME RATHER ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALRIGHT THEN WE'LL GO TO ITEM
THIRTY TWO WHICH IS AT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND THEN EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND IT'S THAT ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IS.
FOR DOWNEY POLICE TACTICAL TEAM
AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND.
VEHICLES AGAIN FOR THE DOWNEY
POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE THERE ANY.
FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
THIS ITEM. ONE THIRTY TWO RIGHT
WILL MOVE TO ITEM THIRTY THREE
WHICH IS A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION OF SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION. FOR THE BUTTE COUNTY
JAIL PROJECT -- ANY.
SPEAKERS WE WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY THREE ALL RIGHT WE WILL
MOVE TO ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS A PROPOSAL
FOR A HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND OVER FOUR YEARS.
FOR A EXPAND THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY TASK FORCE.
TO A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SAFETY TASK FORCE.
ARE THERE ANY [inaudible]
THE SPEAKERS IN RELATIONSHIP. TO
THIS ITEM.
OKAY WE'LL GO NOW TO NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS REQUESTING
FIVE MILLION.
OR DOJ.
MINISTER A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR CITIES COUNTIES AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO PROVIDE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS.
ARE THERE ANY FOLKS WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK TO THAT.
OKAY WELL NOW GOOD ITEM THIRTY
SIX THE BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE THIS IS AN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION OF
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WE HAVE
ANY SPEAKERS.
WHO WERE ON TO ADDRESS US ON
THAT ITEM?
RIGHT BEING.
NINE I'M AS I INDICATED BEFORE
WE'VE BE HOLDING THESE ITEMS --
OPEN -- I KNOW THAT SOME OF THEM.
I HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE MAY
REVISE I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TO
WHAT DEGREE BUT WILL OBVIOUSLY
LEARNED THAT.
OVER THE NEXT WEEK -- SO THESE
ARE BEING HELD OPEN.
AND WITH THAT.
WOMEN JUST CHECK FOR STAFF WE
HAVE ALL ACTIONS TAKEN CARE OF
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT.
BE I'M.
STATE SENATE.
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE JUDICIARY WILL
CONCLUDE AND ADJOURNED FOR TODAY